all right here we go how did this get
started how did we decide to do this I
was trying to think about that because
it's something something you and I
started interacting on it was somebody
on Twitter somebody I don't know exactly
how it started but I saw you replied
into a tweet from somebody saying hey
great idea why don't why doesn't Jocko
and Tulsi go on the Rogen show and he's
like yeah cool yeah oh man yeah my man
but Jocko he'll say that to anything but
it escalated quickly from there because
I didn't know how to get a hold of you
and then next thing I know you're
texting me with Jocko like so are you
serious are we doing this or what well
it just seemed like such a good idea
hi whoever it was salute yeah thank you
just seemed like a wise thing to get
together because I'm both of your
veterans and both of you I'm sure have
things you agree on and disagree on but
you're you're in a really unique
position here you know and and since
you've been on the podcast a lot of
things have happened big the big one is
when you rightly called out Kamala
Harris on her her past and what she's
done and and then it seems like
everybody's attacking you it's like that
opened up the floodgates and then
there's all these hit pieces on in me as
a person observer watching from the
outside is like wow look at the machine
work look at the attack dogs go like
look at this like very transparent ah so
if you're paying attention if you're
paying attention to thing is if you're
on the outside and you watch it all
happen then you go oh I see what's going
on but if you just happened upon one of
those articles yeah you go ho she's an
Assad supporter oh she's a terrible
person
oh she's a this and a dad and it was
amazing it was amazing to watch like I
don't I've never met anybody like like
you that's run for president like I knew
you when people didn't know you that
well and then all sudden people know you
way more and now you're a kind of a
household name so to watch this process
and to watch all the machinery sort of
move in your direction amping up Carole
it's very interesting yeah
I mean that that literally is is our
challenge here is is we are up against
the most powerful overall political
machine when you when you look at this
this machine that's revved up their
engines to try to you know define me as
something that cast suspicion or doubts
or whatever in people's minds you know
pushing information that isn't true or
all of these different things and I
think there's a few reasons for it
our challenge is like yeah we are
battling the political establishment in
Washington and it's because I'm telling
the truth it's because I'm challenging
the status quo that they represent and
and that they've profited off for for a
very long time so you know my campaign
we don't take any contributions from
PACs or lobbyists fueled completely by
contributions from individual people and
they are out spending us by many many
multiples where we need help to
challenge their narrative with the truth
telling me eight this is who I am this
is why I'm running for president this is
the experience in the background that I
bring to this job we've got to be able
to bypass that mainstream corporate
media and just go directly to voters and
what is the experience of being attacked
feel like god I feel like I'm used to it
so just I mean it's just like it's it's
it's nothing that I've ever really taken
personally because I understand the
situation you know I understand that you
know whatever the smears are however
radical they are you know it shows me
that they feel threatened and they are
concerned about both the unifying
message that I'm bringing because we
have Democrats Republicans libertarians
independents who are joining this
coalition that that is fueling our
campaign and it's a campaign of by and
for the people and and one that's that's
actually speaking the truth that's
calling for an end to these regime
change
roars calling for you know a
de-escalation of tensions between the
United States and other nuclear-armed
countries and end to this new Cold War
nuclear arms race actually hey let's
focus our limited taxpayer dollars on
actually serving the needs of our people
that that's really the message that
we're bringing and it scares the hell
out of them what's interesting is for me
again as an outsider it's it's a clear
clear recognition that what they want
versus what they say they want are two
very different exactly the Democratic
Party's party's always been like we want
a woman okay I got you a woman how about
a woman is a veteran check how about a
woman that's a congressman how about
that congresswoman veteran minority
minority from Hawaii all these positives
these trying to dig up dirt on you they
don't have anything that should be
behind you
they should have wind in your sails but
on the other thing they're saying is
that you know in order for democrat to
beat Donald Trump in 2020 you're gonna
have to be able to take Trump voters
away from him you're gonna have to win
over those independents who stayed home
in 2016 or even some of those Democrats
who voted for Trump because they feel
like our party has left them behind
guess what
check check check check we're doing all
those things and instead of saying hey
this is really something that maybe we
should get behind instead they're saying
oh my gosh there's something very
suspicious and weird about her because
she's actually stealing voters from
Trump that's yeah that's the big one
right has there ever been someone in
your position that's get gotten caught
in such a crossfire like to be taking
this much heat from the party that
you're you know trying to represent is
it seems I don't remember this happily
they thought Harris had a real shot and
she's sunk Harris's ship that's exactly
what happened I mean if you look at
there's a direct correlation between
where Harris was standing and where
she's at now in that debate it just you
put holes in her boat which which was
you know I was raising some very
important issues related to criminal
justice reform you know ending the
federal marijuana prohibition and
essentially pointing to to leadership
because we're all asking to to lead this
country and bring the experience that
each of us has that's
very distinct and different and and her
whole campaign was based on the premise
of being a prosecutor for the people
being the Attorney General here in
California and I you know III okay
you you've said you're proud of your
record this is what you have done when
you are in a position to make a positive
change for the people instead you chose
to do otherwise and I think that speaks
louder louder than words when you had
more bullets in the chamber to because
there was other things you didn't even
like you didn't really touch upon her
saying to single mothers that she was
going to prosecute them and lock them up
if they didn't get their kids and skip
and school laughing as she did so yeah I
mean that's the I've seen her talk about
that as if it's a good idea yeah that
this was a good solution yeah I mean
here single mom into with with the fear
of jail if their kid didn't go to school
yeah that that's that's the challenge of
this this debate format that's that's so
frustrating is you know you've got 60 to
75 seconds to get your point across to
be able to talk about hey here's my
position here's what I would do with you
know North Korea here's how I would deal
with you know immigration reform in 60
seconds or less
Jaakko I don't even know how you stand
politically which of lares cuz you're
one of the few guys that's just not
defined politically online because
people think of you as such a savage
they leave all the politics out of it
there's God I don't know what he's get
up gets up at four o'clock in the
morning leaves a puddle of sweat
he's America he's Team America like it
seems like you don't have this thing
with like left or right you don't have
this right or left distinction ya know
what's really interesting if you look at
the demographics of like the people I
meet when I go and speak it's it's
everyone it's everyone from every
different spectrum and I can yeah I'm
just talking my political beliefs are
like hey I I believe in individual
freedom well that seems to me it's kind
of hard to argue against that right yeah
yeah I believe in individual freedom and
with that goes some level of individual
responsibility mmm yep okay I don't
think the government is the great
solution to a lot of our problems you
know so for me it's like a smaller
government probably a better thing
and I think probably why you get this
impression from me is I actually have a
balanced I believe that the solutions
are somewhere balanced and in America
right now that that doesn't really get a
lot of traction because everything is
broken down into such little tiny sound
bites of your either Pro this or you're
against it and there's no gray area and
by the way if you believe this you know
if you believe yes and I believe no I
actually hate you that's and I'm going
to attack you and that's why when when I
started going back and forth with Tulsi
like I you know I kind of get a gist of
what she thinks I'm like oh cool guess
what I think she surfs she trains
martial arts she plays she plays ukulele
no I can hang out with her name she even
if our political beliefs aren't 100%
aligned which my political beliefs
aren't 100 cent aligned with anybody
does that mean that I hate her and I'm
never gonna talk to him to call her out
no actually it's like oh cool oh that's
an interesting perspective because one
thing that gets tied into all these
things nowadays is our ego right our ego
we paint ourselves into a corner where
it's like I believe this and now the
last thing we can do is is say oh
actually no that's a good point Joe you
you want to thought of it from that
perspective before and also just
thinking of what other people's
perspectives are cuz you know you just
talked about single moms well you got to
take that into perspective because it
might be easy for me to say cuz I've got
kids but I got a wife and and we can
make things happen but all the single
moms over here working two three jobs
you know you always talked about me
getting up at 4:30 in the morning and I
always say look there's single moms out
there that are getting up at 3:30 in the
morning to go work their first shift at
the diner so they can get to their
second shift at the grade school or
whatever they're working so they could
do their third shift that's some other
restaurant at night like okay that's
going on I gotta understand that
perspective and we all have to
understand that perspective and the last
thing when you talk about this 60 second
answers which which is insane and you
know I've been interviewed on TV before
a bunch as well and it's actually crazy
it's when you compare it to a podcast
it's completely crazy that you have to
fit your thoughts and do one sentence
maybe two sentences and the 24-hour news
cycle that were on every news story that
comes out is the end of the world right
it's like the end of the
everything that happens is hey Trump did
this or Pelosi did that this is the end
of the world just like when if if
Hillary got elected it's the end of the
world if Trump gets elected as the end
of the world it had early on right after
Trump got elected somebody I was doing a
reddit AMA and as soon as I signed on
for my reddit AMA up pops this question
and it's clearly the guy had spent a lot
of time writing it and it was this this
sort of breakdown of the Russians and
Trump and all this negativity and and
you know I basically took his whole
paragraph and I answered it know in one
sentence I said America is stronger than
one man and that's the truth like hey
America is stronger than one man one man
is not going to take down this country
that's that's the way it is right it's
hardship to turn look at what Trump's
got accomplished you know he he's
working as hard as he can to get stuff
done and he could barely move the needle
right that's the way it is and on top of
that look at what happens with our
political system
you know we had Karger oh there's a
backlash against Carter we have Reagan
right oh you know you know these things
go back and forth we end up with Clinton
then we end up with Bush you know the
and then we end up with Obama and then
we end up with Trump so there's a
balance that happens out so when I think
of my political beliefs or where I stand
politically it's like oh I stand you
you're not gonna be able to place me
very well because I'm gonna listen to
what different people have to say I'm
gonna try and understand what their
perspectives are and then I'm gonna say
oh not what's best for me or what
satisfies my ego but what's good for
America well it actually makes sense for
America and that's what I would move
forward on tells you if you thought at
all about doing a podcast of your own I
have it's it's been it's been a just a
function of time and capacity almost
like you could just have someone record
some of your thoughts while you're on
tour and just do it you know like it
doesn't have to be over produced yeah
just real simple release it but that
ability to get those thoughts out there
in a way where you you can form full
sentences external or ideas express your
concerns talk about it without the
pressure of this buzzer when when you're
in the middle something congresswoman
Congress
congresswoman they gotta cut the
commercials room yeah the tide is
waiting so damn crazy yeah this is how
we decide our leaders yeah and the idea
that isn't it possible can't someone
step up can't Apple or [ __ ] Samsung
or something step up and say alright
we're gonna we are going to advertise at
the beginning of this show and then
we're gonna promote the whole show so
the whole show we're gonna just let it
run with no commercial interruptions no
no in length let's let's do a few hours
why should happen why we're doing an
hour like why is it two hours why it
should be as long as it takes to get I
mean didn't Lincoln do speeches that
were hours long
you know what yelling right no
microphone yeah it's it's so strange
that we have decided that this
commercial oriented meaning it has to be
sandwiched in between commercials that
this is the way we are going to let our
potential future leaders discuss the
most important thing on earth and it's
going to be interrupted by what gum
between it's so dumb and and people are
getting really turned off by it because
they have alternatives they have
alternatives and they're not getting
anything of value from the conversation
that's happening on these these debates
that are really like political reality
TV they are completely set up for
conflict and confrontation to drive up
ratings so that they can make more money
the corporate media can make more money
the first debate had something like
twenty two million viewers the one that
we just did I think had six point six
million viewers and I meet people almost
every single day they're like man I
don't got time for that yeah I don't get
anything from it from it anyway yeah and
you know rather than rather than it
being this this money driven ratings
driven venture which which you know the
media is is doing across the board both
its debates and kind of what issues
they're choosing to cover and go back to
like the League of Women Voters you know
who used to actually host presidential
forums that would have real questions
about real issues that people care about
and in a way that's not broken up by
commercial breaks and advertisement so
that people can make money
yeah and this is not hard to do no
YouTube is available for virtually
anyone who wants to set up an account
this all could be done and it could be
done very easily I mean it's the where
we're showing is the fragility that this
this antiquity this this ancient system
that doesn't make any sense
and we're seeing it evaporate before our
eyes and with a guy like Trump and then
people are using these debates knowing
that they're going to get these sound
bites and knowing that and and you could
see some of them work like yours with
caramel Harrison and some of them don't
like when she was attacking Elizabeth
Warren for not wanting Trump to get
kicked off a Twitter like do you read
his Twitter it's fantastic
keep I'm on this the best way we
understand who he really is
yeah I mean you can get some of that out
of speeches but when he posts a picture
of Greenland with a giant truck tower in
it and says I promise not to do this
listen if you're on Team America you
want that guy to keep tweeting you
called it a while ago when you when you
say hey no one
there's no comedians that have run that
have that skill which Trump has of that
cracking jokes making fun of people
letting the other jokes roll off of his
back because he doesn't care what people
say about him basically and no one's
really had to contend with that until
now yeah it's really interesting like no
one knows how to handle it it's really
fun I mean when you watch the original
Republican debates when he was running
for president and he starts attacking
these guys you see them it's just it's
it's a it's a nutty place to watch what
was it do you get to hang out with
Kamala Harris backstage no no I mean
there's everybody know there's there
there's like a just like a little
holding area kind of space like a lot
smaller than this room so you all you're
all hanging out in there together
um during the commercial breaks yeah but
usually anything contact with her no
maybe every now and then but I I
honestly like yeah I I'm probably not on
the top of her friend list yeah you sank
my battleship and then
did I mean Hillary Clinton yeah I wasn't
no how what's up with that war how's it
going you know she's the matriarch of
the of the Clinton family and now there
she is the hero to many people of the
Democratic Party and you two are
scrapping it does that start when you
did that start you did you supported
Bernie in 2016 is that where it started
yeah okay and that was something yeah
back in 2016 I was the vice chair of the
Democratic National Committee therefore
as an officer the DNC had to remain
neutral in the presidential election
which was my plan to do so
I really made the decision to resign
from that seat so that I could endorse
Bernie Sanders largely be car actually
largely because of his difference with
Hillary Clinton and foreign policy you
know Hillary Clinton had you know very
much of an interventionist in my opinion
kind of the the Warhawk regime change
war policy that she had shown throughout
her time both in the administration as
well as as US senator and Bernie Sanders
you know lean the under way he's more of
a non interventionist and I saw that in
those debates at that time the
conversations that were had the media
was not bringing up this difference
between the two of them so the voters
could make an informed choice of who
they want their commander-in-chief to be
which to me just as you know as a
soldier as a veteran as in America I'm
like how can you not be putting this
issue at the forefront so I resigned
from that position endorse Bernie
Sanders started going out and just
talking about and raising these issues
on the campaign trail but I remember one
of the first interviews that I did on
MSNBC the host of the show saying aren't
you afraid of what the Clintons will do
to you said this on live television you
know my answer was no obviously but it
was amazing it was it was interesting to
see the reaction like the the days after
when I first went back to DC after I
made that announcement of endorsement
and friends of mine you know politicians
in Washington they were like man tulsi
like
go with God like if you get into some
sort of verbal altercation with Joe
Biden there's no concern for your life
I'm not saying it's real or not
yeah but the rumor is always there's a
thing yeah I don't think it is really
some of it most of it let's say it's all
made up the fact that that's out there
that the thought is out there that they
will whack you well there's there's I
mean the people who are saying hey look
you know there are lists that are kept
and your political career will be over
that was really the message that I got
from from people who've been around the
block a few times I think the most
recent thing that that came up with what
Hillary Clinton said about me is is not
it's not a spat between two people it
really just shows the the complete
difference and the conflict in our
foreign policy views of the what I call
the bush Clinton doctrine of
interventionism and regime change wars
and war mongering versus what I'm
putting forward which is let's stop the
regime change war world's police
policies work to end this new Cold War
an arms race put the interests of the
American people first always ensuring
that we have a strong and capable ready
military to defend our nation and our
people and honoring that service and
sacrifice that that our troops give by
only sending them on missions worthy of
their sacrifice maximizing diplomacy
engagement with other countries in the
world through cooperation rather than
conflict and always seeing war as a last
resort
so that conflict that you're seeing in
the media that's been playing out and
again why you're seeing so much of the
corporate media and the political
machine attacking me is because of this
difference is because of this change in
foreign policy that I'm bringing about
because when it comes right down to it
you know whether you're going back to
back to the Cold War back to Vietnam or
back to you know the Iraq war
overthrowing Saddam Hussein Libya
Gaddafi the media has always kind of
been this cheerleading voice for these
Wars to happen sending a very clear
narrative out to the American people and
I think it comes down to it's good
business for them it's good ratings I
want money I want to talk to you about
that but I want to talk to you about
what she said to you or about you oh
yeah that she said that you were a
Russian asset that was that was the
insinuation right yeah like what was the
base of that and how does someone who is
baseless so that's what's weird right
how does someone who was running for
president and it is one of the most
prominent politicians in our country how
do they get away with something some
saying something that's that's such a
huge accusation with no information to
back it up it would be a good question
for a a normal person but when you look
at the power of the Clinton machine when
you look at the power of the political
establishment which is made up of people
who are either you know part of the the
Clinton so-called family or who are part
of this political establishment that is
built on the same foundation that that
she Hillary Clinton laid when you look
at the media establishment who've been
pushing a lot of the same narrative a
lot of the same message then you can see
how somebody gets away with calling a
sitting member of Congress a candidate
for president Soldier actively serving
the Army National Guard veteran of two
middle-east deployments basically a
traitor to the country that I love and
that I'm willing to lay my life down for
and to get away with it without any
evidence or base whatsoever not just
that but no pushback no that was the
most bizarre thing no one said hold on
you what are you saying
she is you're saying she's a Russian
asset define that what do you mean by
that do you mean an unwitting Russian
asset are you saying that Russia's
behind her to try to do something
against Bernie or Elizabeth Warren or
whatever the consensus pic is like what
are you saying
there was no questions like that there
were no questions like that and and look
even if there were witting or unwitting
so she's basically either saying that
I'm a traitor to my nation or that I am
an unwitting asset which means basically
you are too stupid and too
naive to know that you were being used
to further the interests of a nation
other than our own both of which are are
deeply deeply offensive and again
without any base and I think that that's
the like this is bigger this isn't this
is really not about me that the danger
here of what she did and how the media
responded and how almost every single
other candidate for president refused to
comment refused to denounce what she
said Bert I think Bernie is an exception
Marianne Williamson and yang couple of
them had the courage to say hey look
this is ridiculous
the fact that that was that was the
response is really it has a chilling
effect on our freedom of speech in this
country and it sends a message that
whether it's Tulsi Gabbard or any other
American or any other veteran who dares
to stand up and challenge the
establishment challenge this foreign
policy narrative call for peace call for
an end to these senseless unnecessary
regime change wars than you two can be
smeared your character can be smeared do
you ever think you could reach a tipping
point where this happens enough this
kind of thing happens where you just say
alright I'm done with in this case the
Democratic Party I mean even after what
they did to Bernie in 2016 right that
I'm sure that had to be a tipping point
for a lot of people that said wait a
second this is the guy we wanted and you
totally hosed him and now we got this
this woman over here but we didn't want
him how much how many times can this
happen before people go oh you know I'm
done with this I I see this as something
that's bigger than just the Democratic
Party because we see this we see how
this kind of foreign policy elite and
establishment in Washington it has
crossed both parties over different
times and it's something that I think
goes much deeper than that I'm working
to bring about reforms in the Democratic
Party to make it so that it is more
democratic more open more transparent
you know more inclusive and welcoming of
people who you know may agree on some
issues disagree on others but one that
is actually serving as as a platform for
the people fighting for the people
thinking about what's in the best
interests of the people that that's the
kind of change in reform that that I'm
working to bring about in the party but
I think that forces that we're
challenging here are actually much
bigger than that I mean you got to give
a lot of credit to the Republican Party
because the establishment Republicans
the last human being in the world that
they wanted has to run for president on
the Republican ticket was Donald J Trump
and they tried they tried but once he
was in they said that's our president
yeah and that's a very wise thing to do
and and you know that's that that's
where the fear is with a lot of
Democrats that someone is going to go
independent and that's someone who is
popular perhaps you would go independent
and suck a lot of the votes away from
the Democratic Party people disagree
with the direction it's going and then
that's how the Republicans would win
yeah I'm not I'm not going to do that
I've been asked that a ton of time since
I don't know months ago and every single
time I've been asked I've said the
answer is no I'm running to be the
Democratic nominee I will not run as a
third party candidate and I think that's
something else that's that's been
interesting and again very transparent
if you're paying attention is no matter
how many times I answer that question
from reporters and no matter how many
times my answer is consistently the same
no that was another thing that Hillary
Clinton and others continue to point out
like oh well we think we think she's
going to run as a third party candidate
and she's going to be the reason that
Donald Trump wins no and it and they're
clearly trafficking and things that
aren't true again why to raise that
question people's minds and to raise
that suspicion and to do their best to
try to to undermine the support that
we're getting from people they did they
did that interview with you on the view
oh you saw that and yeah and they they
said they said something about Richard
Spence Spencer the white supremists and
because he said so this is of all the
things they bring up they say Richard
Spencer a white supremacist Nazi said he
could vote for you that's what he
decided to bring up well the view is I
mean we have to really be thankful that
it exists because without that level of
discourse on television without being
able to watch those geniuses banter
around some of the most important ideas
of today I don't know where we would be
I think it elevates us as a society as a
civilization and it also shows the rest
of the world how it's done if you really
want to see how the the baddest country
on earth deals with political discourse
and social issues watch those gals
because they got it down
bunch of damn geniuses you're good they
throw that out there and you you know
once it's out there hey it's out there
there's someone else somewhere that
heard that cliff Richards and that's
what they're running with yeah
that's today though today is there's so
much data right there's so much
information that all they need is one
little smeary thing to toss your way and
then people would say oh she's an Assad
supporter oh she's this Oh Richards
Spencer's favorite candidate that one
and then like oh yeah I vote for her the
team this is what we see on Twitter all
it's a giant issue with the left to the
left eats itself way more than any other
party and I don't know what that is
about liberals in general that seem to
really truly enjoy calling each other
out for not being liberal enough but
it's it's very strange it's it's it's
it's such so obviously destructive and
it shows that there's no good leadership
at the top of the heap because at the
top of the heap ever to be hey we're all
in this together okay we can disagree on
some stuff but if we start attacking
each other and makes the other side
stronger so let's let's cut the [ __ ]
publicly and let's talk this through and
that's pretty much exactly the
Republicans have done for the most part
yeah and as Italy you know from a
leadership perspective it is almost
always best to look at things in a
balanced way and say oh I got this this
part of my team over here that wants to
do this extreme thing and the other part
of team wants to do the opposite extreme
thing the answer is gonna be somewhere
in the middle why don't I just find a
good kind of solution that's somewhere
in the middle and of course the fringes
are going to be a little bit mad okay I
get that but they're the fringes but the
bolt
of people and what's good for the bulk
of people is to make this kind of
balanced decision and home forward with
it but we don't get that kind of logic
inside of these leaders especially when
they're running your president yeah
which is you know they run and then as
soon as they get in they're running for
re-election yeah you know it's it's just
it's so frustrating as a citizen sit
back and watch this going from the
debate format to the way things are
handled it's just I don't understand why
there have been radical improvements
there's improvements and imagine getting
a computer from 1990 and trying to do
your work on it be like this hunk of
[ __ ] like what doesn't someone do
something better well we have the same
exact political system that we had
before the internet with the internet
it's an it hasn't been updated at all
and it doesn't make any sense
yeah it's just it's it's so bonkers and
we sit around and we wait for this
magical day in November where we're
gonna all fix it and we all know that
it's not gonna get fixed and it's just
it's just a weird place to be in where
everyone's aware there's an issue and no
one's fixing it I when I look at this
upcoming election I have no idea right
right and you know I had a pretty good
idea who was gonna win in 2016 just like
everyone else I've figured of course you
know Hillary Clinton I used you knew I
talked about oh yeah I talked I talked
about it and triggered my Netflix
special for 2016 I'm like he's that
close you guys I go president Trump
could be a real thing because it's I was
seeing I was going across the country
and doing these gigs all over the place
and like these people are angry they're
angry at liberals they're angry at
people that are you know forcing
policies they don't agree with whether
it's social policies or economic
policies there's so many people that
thought that Bernie Sanders gonna steal
all their money well I would say that I
was like he might win every time someone
said oh if you believe in if you believe
in border security you're a racist yeah
right hey if you believe in border
security you're racist so that makes
Obama racist yeah and but but all those
people that heard that like
I'm not right what are you talking about
I'm voting for Trump right exact and
that is what happened still what's
happened it's still playing out right
now you know where people are saying
exactly that that if you believe in
secure borders then you must be
anti-immigrant and you must be you must
be a racist and vice versa you know they
look at the opposite side and make the
opposing argument rather than taking
that sensible approach and saying hey
how about we secure our borders using
the most effective and cost-efficient
means possible and update our
immigration laws so that they are humane
and that they actually serve the
interests of our country our economy our
families education and so on and so
forth I mean this is something that yeah
Republicans and Democrats if you just
sit down and have the conversation say
oh yeah well I actually agree with that
like you're saying like okay that's a
really good point we maybe we should do
it this way maybe we should do it that
way but if we can agree on the objective
then we can have the meaningful
conversation about how to get there
rather than continuing what we are doing
where we're seeing we have not seen an
update to our immigration laws for
decades I think since Reagan actually we
have not seen a comprehensive
immigration reform which we so
desperately need it's because honestly
both sides are so busy throwing crap at
each other and arrows at each other
because it's about partisanship and
getting the political win rather than
actually solving the problem the
difference it's easy to cry racism when
you look at the difference in the border
of Mexico and the border of Canada
because border of Canada it's like giant
landing strips like come on through this
woods and then there's a huge gap in the
woods it's not the opposite of a fence
it's like we're gonna make it easier for
you to cross we're gonna show you where
the lioness have you seen the border you
see the border cam yeah but it's various
you put the economy in Canada is not
gonna force people to try and get to
America pretty nice yeah that's the
issue right and the real issue is
there's parts of the world you know
whatever you want to use third world
whatever phrase you want to use there's
parts of the world economically where if
you're born there you're kind of screwed
you know it's really hard to get by it's
really hard if you're living in a poor
community in Mexico that's run by the
cartel
what a [ __ ] roll the dice you know you
just you got a bad hand of cards that's
what it is
and until that gets balanced out which
traditionally takes centuries right for
close cut nearby countries to sort of
for everything to even out especially
when the politics are so different
between Mexico and the United States and
Mexico is just insanely corrupt sorry
Mexico but I mean often I mean you saw
would happen with chapo son he gets
arrested by the Mexican military and
then the cartels forced them to release
him and I can't take them back
sorry yeah we'll figure this out later
yeah okay and and that's something that
you know that that's the kind of of
change and the rooting out of corruption
reforms that can only happen organically
yes within Mexico could you imagine
Chaco as a military man a situation like
that happened in the United States where
the some cartel forces the United States
military to release a prisoner no no did
you imagine no did you imagine the
backlash there are so many rednecks that
would just be just spending all day
filling cartridges god yeah you want to
find out what the second amendments
really for if that ever took place in
this country if there was ever a
situation this country we felt like we
were really overrun by a cartel where
they were taking over cities like like
what's going on in Mexico it would be
you would understand how rapidly
independent this country really is yeah
yes yeah and and even you know when you
talk about people that are living down
in Mexico that wanted to come here it's
like oh you knew you feel for them
because they got a bad deal but a lot of
the people that are trying to come here
are ms-13 gangsters looking to come up
here and whatever do what they're gonna
do in America where there's even more
money to be made off of illegal
activities yeah if you could throw the
Wonder Woman lasso of truth around them
and find out what they're really all
about if you just pour you want to make
it hey come on in you're hard worker
excellent so we're my grandparents come
on in you know but it's just the idea
that we should all have open borders and
everybody should be able to go anywhere
like
yeah boy there's a lot a lot of people
that you don't want coming here and it
probably should be a good idea to check
people for criminal history and violent
pasts and you know that see if you
remember the cartel sneaked into Mexico
there are just you know I think there
there are practical limitations even if
you said okay well you know we're gonna
we want to welcome anybody and everybody
in the world who is suffering and who is
in need of help or a better life to come
to United States it's just not realistic
we don't have the resources as a country
to be able to do that when you know look
here in LA I was on Skid Row a couple
couple of about a month or two ago
coming visiting there the homeless
crisis in Hawaii is is the worst per
capita of any state in the country it's
something that's affecting both urban
cities and rural communities across the
country we have you know what almost 80
million people who are uninsured and
underinsured in this country you can't
get the medicine they need and who are
literally driving their kid to Mexico to
buy insulin because they have diabetes
and they can't afford to get the
medicine here at home we got a lot of
issues and a lot of challenges that
we've got to deal with and my view is
we've got to be pragmatic and practical
in how we are seeing the situation
looking at what our objective is and how
does that best serve the people of this
country and then figure out okay what's
what's the best way for us to get there
and I think that's what's unfortunately
lost in this hyper partisan political
atmosphere whether you're talking about
what's going on in Washington and the
media or what's going on in Twitter
where you have these extremes you have
this rush to judgment when people aren't
taking the time both to sit down and
first try to understand the problem like
you know this goes back to like military
decision making process 101 first you
got to understand the problem right
you're trying to solve come up with
what's the objective make sure it's
achievable and then build your plan and
then execute that just doesn't happen
these days because it's more about
calling the other guys names or you know
it having this race on this happens all
the time there's like something happens
in the news for the political candidates
running for president it's who can get
their tweet out the fastest on the issue
we saw this recently with
the situation in Syria with the Kurds
and who can get the tweet out the fast
people are asking me like hey what do
you have to say what do you have to say
I'm like I'm trying to understand the
situation first I'm actually trying to
understand what happened and why we are
in the situation that we're in once I do
that I'll let you know what I think and
that was another one of those
end-of-the-world scenarios that unfolded
you know we Trump hold the troops out of
out of that area and it was like oh the
world's gonna end and look there was
some bad stuff that happened I get it
some Isis folks as folks some Isis
terrorists murderers escaped I got that
some some Kurds were killed like some
bad stuff happened but it wasn't the end
of the world and and one thing you know
I was at my second deployment to Iraq we
were we started doing counterinsurgency
operations instead of counter-terrorist
operations so we we changed our strategy
and as we did this we were we were
starting to kill a decent amount of bad
guys about of these insurgents so a few
weeks go by and I got a message from up
my chain of command and they're like hey
joko we get that you're doing these
missions but right now we're not seeing
any changes in the metrics as far as
enemy attacks that are happening
happening right and luckily I had read
the counterinsurgency manual that was
written by General Petraeus and and I
part of that explains that a the average
counterinsurgency takes seven years to
work itself out right and so I said hey
you know boss the average
counterinsurgency takes seven years to
to flush itself out it's only been three
weeks can I get support for some more
time here to work through this and he's
like okay yeah you know makes sense but
my point is it's the same thing here
we think that some news event that we
can fully understand a news event within
one hour of it happening we don't have
any understanding we you need to let
these things develop and and see where
the actual long-term effects are we
can't be snapping judgments and making
radical decisions or split decisions
when we have to actually assess what is
really going on and
the press for sure is like snap
precision snap decision snap position
and you can see it's comical to flip
back and forth between the two to the
left-wing media in the right-wing media
and one of them is the greatest this is
never another one's the most horrible
thing has ever happened and there you go
and you know no one can even make an
assessment of what just happened cuz it
only happened 14 minutes ago how about
we see where it plays out
it's about being first rather than
actually being accurate and presenting
the American people with here's what has
gone on you can form your own opinion
you can form your own conclusion but
here's the course of events that took
place ABCD and E and that's that's
exactly what we're missing
in in most of the time I think it's what
we're talking about earlier I think
we're poisoned by this desire to have
our information fed to us very quickly
and that the fact that there's so much
information coming at us we don't have
enough time to sit back and read a
manual on how long it takes
counterinsurgency efforts to be fruit
fruition to reach fruition the the fact
that that's hitting you in the military
that you would think that the most
pragmatic the most disciplined people
that understand the long game that are
playing 3d chess those are the people
that you would want telling people like
you what you can and can't do the fact
that that kind of thinking is even
filtering down to Special Ops groups is
crazy
well what's nice is we do have
decentralized command inside the
military so when I'm telling my boss
this what's going on my boss doesn't
like shut up and do what I told you to
do my boss like okay make sense explain
it to me okay got it yeah that makes
sense cool move forward that's that's a
very positive thing in the military
everyone thinks that the military is
this rigid structured way where you just
obey the chain of command you don't you
don't fear from that at all but if my
boss tells me to do something that
doesn't make any sense I'm gonna say hey
boss this actually is a bad plan we
should do it a different way
and if I have a good boss my boss says
okay I didn't see that angle and that's
another thing that you know when Tulse
he's talking about how politicians we
come up with a plan and then we start
executing the plan guess what once you
start executing a plan some other things
are gonna come to come to life right and
you as a leader have to say hey you know
what we started executing this it's
going pretty good but I didn't foresee
this happening I'm making an adjustment
here it is here's what we're gonna do
and I'm gonna wait for that feedback to
come to me the promise people are so
insecure or slash their egos so big
that they won't they'll just I just
gonna stick with the same plan no matter
everyone else is dumb no used to need to
see it through it's like no actually we
need to make some changes because they
you know they are afraid of saying hey
my initial assessment might have been
inaccurate or wrong yeah and and I think
that that also just points the bigger
point for the political leadership the
civilian leadership that sets the policy
that the military execute is so often
lacks that foresight and that that
planning of actually looking okay if we
pursue course of action a you know we
call here will be the second third
fourth order of effects right here's how
you know the enemy or the opponent is
likely to react or here's how other
actors are likely to react to our action
so we can try to anticipate that and
then we can okay this is how we would
respond this is how they're likely to
respond actually go through this so that
we don't end up in the situation that we
too often find ourselves in where you're
like alright here's the here's the
mission guys go for it and then you
whether it's a week or a month or a year
Lear like hey how the hell do we find
ourselves here it's like you failed as
leaders the leaders of our country
failed to ask those questions about you
know what happens what happens next you
know after we go in and topple Saddam
Hussein and we completely obliterate the
entire Iraqi military what actually
happens next what will be the
consequences to this what will be the
cost to our troops our military what
will be the cost to the Iraqi people
what will be the cost to American
taxpayers is the is the object do we
know what the objective is is it
achievable
what's our end state an exit strategy
when you look back and I've just I've
seen this throughout my seven years in
Congress sitting on the Foreign Affairs
Committee sitting on the Armed Services
Committee where we're questioning and
providing oversight over the Department
of Defense and Department of State
asking leaders these questions and when
were not given answers or given
ambiguous answers or things like you
know I asked secretary mattis once in a
hearing about how al-qaeda has gotten so
strong in Syria to where I mean right
now they they control an entire city
entire city of Idlib is controlled by
al-qaeda and I asked him at that time I
said well why aren't we
going after al-qaeda in Syria in a very
serious and concerted way and his answer
was while it's complicated it's
complicated
and it's it's it it's frustrating to say
the least but I think it's been a very
transmits been a very clear window into
the lack of foresight and good judgment
and just the ability to look at these
challenges and situations with that that
basic understanding in a non-emotional
way and understand what's the objective
cost and consequences before we launch
this action I want to talk about
something you brought up briefly earlier
about the media being sort of
cheerleaders yeah for a lot of these
wars or a lot of these military actions
what do you think that that happens
because this ensures that they get
access do you think it happens because
conflict is good for their business do
you think it happens because if they
don't act as cheerleaders they don't get
access to the leaders and to the the
important politicians and military
leaders I mean I I think that the
underlying driver is that conflict is
good for ratings that's crazy that that
is their decision how to cover things
it's it's the it's the war machine you
know that that they're a part of and
that they're driving that they are a
driving force for you know I think that
yeah there there you know there there
have been reports I think over time I 18
you and Matt Taibbi here Reese you know
where you've got you know journalists
who are more or even you know papers who
are who are more interested in covering
for their you know CIA relationships
rather than actually bringing forward a
story that the American the truth you
know that the American people deserve to
hear so you know I think there there are
other factors there that drive the media
really playing a heavily influential and
dangerous force in continuing to push
this this war mongering narrative that
that is you know I mean it's it's
costly in an immeasurable immeasurable
way
well the coverage is so influential and
that influence it changes the way people
accept or don't accept things that are
happening internationally you know when
there's something I mean what was the do
you remember when oh there was a time
when Obama had talked about attacking
Syria yes doing something was in 2013
the entire country was like [ __ ] you
like it was it was she was my first year
in Congress I mean it was one of the the
biggest like rejections of an idea
global or a nationally that I've ever
seen and then he kind of backed off it
and yeah I was like oh okay I think I
think that was one of the most brave
decisions that he made to back off from
it where he actually you know he didn't
take that position in that example of
just kind of being the obstinate
stubborn like nope here's what I said
and he drew this red line I'm not gonna
go back on it no matter what no he did I
think he listened to the American people
and ultimately he chose diplomacy well
this is an area where people have been
critical of you is your position on
Syria and the fact that you had met with
Assad and this is something that gets
brought up and again it gets brought up
in these little soundbite things that
are seeking to define you without any
nuance or any any complexity they try to
let light just let this little tiny
sentence or to define your position then
they can repeat that to other people
without really knowing what they're
talking about
yeah what is your position on Syria and
Assad and how did all this conflict and
all this weirdness with you and the
subject begin I think I think it it goes
back to again the the opposition that
comes towards me from the the political
establishment you know the the corporate
media and the military-industrial
complex because of the the leadership
and the voice that I've been bringing
calling for an end to regime change wars
whether we were talking about the one in
Iraq Libya and in in Syria
look my choice my choice will always be
towards diplomacy
because if we lack the courage to meet
with both adversaries and friends in the
pursuit of our own national security and
peace the only alternative is war period
that's the way it is so I will always
choose to maximize all diplomatic means
and measures and talks and negotiations
to further our interests of peace and
national security
recognizing that war should always be
the last resort if necessary now is this
it's very difficult for people to
understand that these things are
insanely messy and you saying that you
would always lean towards diplomacy does
not mean you support dictators no but
that's exactly the way they frame it
yeah but if you look at the famous
Hillary Clinton speech after Qaddafi was
killed we came we saw he died and she
was laughing Libya is a failed state now
they have they have slaves that they're
auctioning off on YouTube and you could
watch slave auctions that someone filmed
with their camera on their phone and
they upload it to YouTube Libya's gone I
mean it's a chaotic place right now yeah
it wasn't good when Qaddafi was running
Libya but it wasn't as bad as it is now
so the idea that supporting Qaddafi is
supporting a dictatorship and you're
your own monster for supporting and like
maybe not because it's kind of worse now
because the world is a very messy place
and it's not even a matter of
quote-unquote supporting it's just
saying hey we're not going to come in
and overthrow you and write government I
think that's as it seems that that's the
issue here and the contradiction when
people are criticizing me for exercising
diplomacy and calling for an end to the
regime change war that we've been waging
in Syria since 2011 but then they'll say
oh well of course I was against
overthrowing Saddam Hussein in Iraq
right there there's no intellectual
there's no consistency there and I think
the the issue with Libya that that so
often gets overlooked is again we look
at what what will the consequences be
of these regime-change Wars you said I
mean Libya is a completely failed state
there are more terrorist organizations
and strongholds in Libya now than there
ever were before when Gaddafi was there
the people of Libya are suffering far
more now than they were before we also
see this other effect on our own
national security where our regime
change war policy has undermined our
ability to negotiate with Kim jong-un in
North Korea towards denuclearization you
have the leaders of North Korea of time
and time again have said hey look we're
developing nuclear weapons as the only
deterrent that'll work against the
United States coming in and overthrowing
our governments said it over and over
and over again and they've pointed to
examples like Libya saying that well you
guys are saying you want to come in and
negotiate with us to get rid of our
nuclear weapons
you told Gaddafi the same thing so today
Gaddafi get rid of your nuclear weapons
program we'll leave you alone and then
you went in and overthrew Gaddafi why
will this be any different with us and
then you've got John Bolton as as then
the National Security Director for for
trump going on television or giving
speeches saying yeah you know we're
gonna approach North Korea with the
Libya model he said that and so when we
wonder like hey why aren't these and I I
think I think Trump was right now said
it publicly Trump is right to have
direct negotiations with Kim jong-un but
he hasn't gotten anywhere and you've got
to look at why and this is one of the
reasons why continuing hey hey no we're
not gonna overthrow you in your
government Kim Jong I'm but on the other
hand you're you're continuing the
policies that directly undermine your
ability to to make that agreement that
that'll be that'll that'll hold and that
will stay and as a result now you know
we have North Korea that that's nuclear
weapons program is continuing to
escalate their capabilities are
continuing to grow and it poses a threat
not only to you know my folks in in
Hawaii the people of Hawaii given our
proximity North Korea but their
capabilities now they're extending
across the west coast they're extended
extending across the country posing a
very direct existential
to our country and to our people so you
see how that decision that was made
about Libya these decisions that are
ongoing see they're pulling out of the
Iran nuclear agreement North Korea says
hey you guys made an agreement them you
got a different president elected tore
up that agreement why should we think
that's going to be any different with us
so these policy decisions that are being
made are very directly connected in in
having the effect ultimately of
undermining our national security and
making the American people less safe
I'll tell you I think a couple things
come up and just kind of on what your
what you're saying and this is kind of
my perspective on it when you know when
we talk about hey when you go in
somewhere you've got to know what the
end state is you got to know true you
know you got to know where you're going
and when you're gonna leave gotta have
an exit strategy what's really hard
about that is we don't necessarily know
and war is so and predict unpredictable
that you may you know there's there's a
chance that you went in and killed
Qaddafi and then all of a sudden some
benevolent person steps up and all of a
sudden you've got this flourishing
democracy okay with the chance to that
no very small but you don't know that
it's gonna go into this this completely
failed state you have high hopes maybe
your Intel people are saying you this
it's like when we you know when we did
the Bay of Pigs all the Cubans in
America were like yep as soon as you
guys hit the beaches all the Cubans are
gonna be on our side it's gonna be good
to go all the Cubans that supported
America were in America we showed up
there and they were like what are you
doing no this is our country
so we don't necessarily know where we're
gonna go which means you've got to have
once again like the open mind to say oh
this isn't going the way we thought it
was gonna go how we going to adjust
right now to prevent this from getting
worse which means what you really have
to do is prior to intervening in other
countries you have to assess what
sacrifices you are willing to make to to
get the result that is positive and yeah
and it's and those those could be
massive you know I always talk about if
you're gonna go to war you've got to
have the will and that will comes in two
forms number one is the will to kill
because when you go to war you are going
to be killing people you're going to be
killing the enemy and you're gonna be
killing civilians and that
that's not what we're trying to do and
believe me the US military goes through
great lengths to prevent that from
happening but it is gonna happen it's
war so you have to be willing to kill
you have to be willing to have that
happen and you have to be willing to die
because when you go to war there's gonna
be American kids that are not gonna come
home and so you have to have those two
wills that's before you go in so you
can't look at it and say well you know
we can go in a little you can move this
guy and probably it'll turn out okay so
we don't have to worry about what the
sacrifices are gonna be another thing to
think about when we went to war when you
went to world war two World War one
those kids 18 years old 17 years old
those kids went to war until the war was
over they were they went on deployment
like now you know the in the in the Navy
in the Marine Corps to six seven-month
deployment and the army sometimes it's a
14 month deployment and then they're
gonna rotate back to the States in World
War two is like oh cool yeah we're at
war you'll be home when it's over so
five years four years if that was our
attitude going into the war this is so
important to us that johnny is gonna get
on a ship and he's gonna sail to the
Pacific and if he comes home it's gonna
be in three years four years five years
that's what we're talking about that's
the level of commitment we have so when
we start looking at going into other
countries we need to start thinking okay
what level of commitment do we really
have to make this successful and and
like even when I look at Iraq you know I
was in Iraq and fought in Iraq from a
granular perspective being on the ground
Battle of Ramadi 2006 the citizens of
Ramadi the normal citizens of Ramadi
were overjoyed that we were there and it
was like we were we were angels to go
there and help them get rid of these
heinous al Qaeda insurgents which
eventually came became Isis
unfortunately you know we kind of we we
did a great job Ramadi was the model of
counterinsurgency for about seven years
and it was less violent than many cities
in America and I had great pride and at
least
understood the sacrifices my friends
that were killed my friends that never
came home my friends that won't get to
have kids right they did all that they
gave all that and I was able to look
around and say you know what these folks
in this foreign country they're gonna
have an opportunity for freedom and
unfortunately because of politics and
whatever we said okay you know what
we're we're not staying there we're
gonna leave as soon as we left everybody
that been on the ground in Iraq was like
mmm this is probably not a good idea
this is probably not a good idea to bail
out right now we don't need to leave a
massive force there but you know if we
leave a few you know we leave a couple
brigades worth of men then Oh we'll
probably be able to handle any problems
that that happened
well we didn't we left completely and
and those those insurgents that were
there they were like little embers and
they started to they started to get
fired up again and then the next thing
you know you had Isis and by the way
Isis marched back into Ramadi and they
the reports we got from people on the
ground that we knew was that Isis came
in and anyone that had worked with
coalition forces in any level they would
murder the whole family was about 500
families that were completely murdered
so when we talk about these things we
have to be very sure about what we're
gonna do we have to recognize that we
can't predict everything because we
can't I don't care how good you are and
care how many analysis you put on
something when you start throwing human
nature into a leadership vacuum all
these things are gonna break out and
it's gonna it can go very very bad it
can go well too but it can go very very
bad and so what are we willing to
sacrifice what are we willing to spend
how many of our brothers and sisters in
uniform are we willing to sacrifice to
make this happen and how does it help
our national security I believe right
now had we stayed there Iraq would be a
pretty strong positive place right now
if we had kind of completed the mission
the way that we should have again when
we go back and we say okay well what
what what countries is it worth going
into you know where are we gonna go what
how do we draw that line or how do we
make that decision for me this is this
is what we do as leaders what we do as
leaders we look at a situation and and
sometimes you know you can ask yourself
do we have a moral
obligation to go somewhere if there's a
genocide happening if there's another
Rwanda happening where 800,000 Tutsis
are killed in hundred days with machetes
if that's going on do we have a moral
obligation to try and do something to
help that hey that's a decision you have
to meet that's a hard decision to make
as leader because guess what you're
gonna lose 30 40 100 Americans that are
going in there and trying to shut this
thing down but that's the that's the
type of thing we need to think about and
that's why as a leader you want to have
an open mind you want to have your ego
completely out of it because it's real
easy to say oh this is where America
this is what we do this is we're gonna
win it's like no actually we made a bad
decision and we're actually leaving
right now because we think the
expenditure from here on out is going to
be too hot unfortunate I think in Iraq
we paid the upfront expenditure we had
invested lives and treasure to try and
get that play stabilized we had done a
decent job we were almost there and we
left early and all of a sudden we look
around to go but that's why these things
are important to to think about
thoroughly as Tulsi said before you go
we don't know what's going to happen and
you know if you're gonna get in a street
fight Joe like you look as capable as
you are as capable as I am at street
fighting that's great there is that 10
percent chance that that guy pulls out a
knife and sticks it in your neck and are
you willing to sacrifice that now if the
guys doing something to an innocent
person and you go you know what I got to
take that risk right now I'm gonna go in
and I'm gonna get this thing handled
those are hard decisions to make and we
have to think through them if there was
very well said if there was one thing
when I brought you two together that I
thought that you might disagree on it
would be this stance on non
interventionist foreign policy I don't
know if that's even the right word
disagree but I think there's nuances to
these decisions and these things you
taught I think you would agree with that
and then Rwanda what you talked about is
a great example do you have a moral
responsibility to go in when you see
some atrocities being committed I mean
that's one thing that people either pro
or con honors is the United States are
we the police force of the world are we
the moral high ground
yeah III don't just just listening to
jock I think that I don't think that
that we actually disagree very much do
you tell me if I'm wrong but I think
there there are important distinctions
to be made you know my opposition to
regime change wars should not be
mistaken for isolationism nor should it
be mistaken for anything other than what
it is let's stop fighting
regime change wars that are so often
waged in the guise of humanitarianism
but they are pushed forward for other
reasons where there are political
reasons or corporate reasons or whatever
and they try to get the sympathy of the
American people and they use the same
words you know the this guy's a monster
this is this that when you actually peel
back the layers there are ulterior
motives in place that set the pretext to
use our military to go and overthrow a
regime in another country or topple a
dictator that ultimately ends up more
often than not resulting in in the lives
of the suffering more suffering for the
people in the countries we're supposedly
trying to go and help however I'm I've
been very strong on this we're talking
about al Qaeda Isis these other jihadist
terrorists who are a threat to our
national security we need to stay strong
in defeating that threat that is our
function as warriors as service members
in the military is to go and protect and
defend the American people and to take
out those who seek to do us harm in the
case of a genocide like Rwanda where
there is a killing of people at a
massive scale we look to see hey is
there something that we can do to help
end this genocide can we work with other
countries can we bring together a
coalition that can effectively stop this
genocide and if the answer to that is
yes then we should do so but the the
problem that we've seen a lot more
recently is you'll see the word genocide
being used very loosely - I
an excuse to go and say hey well you
know gogo and topple this dictator who
is inflicting a genocide on their own
people without it actually meeting the
criteria of a genocide when really
there's a conflict within though within
the country whether it be based on
politics or power or whatever that's a
very different thing than this then then
like what we saw in Rwanda for example
so as you say I agree I think I think
before we go in and make this decision
to take military action we've really got
to look very carefully at what is the
situation where is the information that
we're coming from is it coming from
people who are pushing their own
narrative for their own interests where
they're not really caring about the
interests of the people in these
countries or the interests of the
American people and our troops they got
their own thing going on we've got to be
able to know that and understand that
and approach this decision not based on
a knee-jerk emotional reaction and
chakra what you were talking about
earlier is so important here that when
you are on one side and the other side
is doing something no matter what you
never said well that makes sense you
hate that other side this is a perfect
example when Trump wanted to pull people
out of Syria people on the Left were
saying no people on the Left were
supporting military action in Syria and
I was like this is this is bonkers
upside down
it's weird yes and that's because they
despise that's they completely hate
Trump yeah and I mean I know you got
friends that hate Trump more than
anything at all I got friends that hate
Trump more than anything in the world
and and it doesn't matter what he does
they have such a passionate hatred for
him that he could he could just you know
cure cancer and and people would say
well he did it for his own good I have
friends that hate him and I have friends
that like him and I have friends that
love him and that's what's hilarious to
me when whenever he does something I
love to call the friends who hate him
and just have them scream and yell and
rant about and go why so worked up man
this is like this quid pro quo King I've
never heard that goddamn expression more
in my entire
like who the hell ever thought that quid
pro quo would be like a gigantic talking
point on every single major new news
station every newspaper yeah it's it's a
it's a weird time conflict wise and in
terms of just people's inability to just
look at things with nuance and look at
the complexity of these conversations
and just say you're on Team Trump or
you're not you're with us or you're
against us you're you Pro this or
you'reyou're anti-democracy I you know
you talk about how Trump's kind of the
guy for the [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
yes and at the the other end of the
spectrum is people that do that they're
they just can't believe it insults their
very being that this guy is is is the
present United States yeah it insults
their very being and they're so offended
by it that it doesn't matter what he
does it's true but then there's so many
people that are like you know what at
least I at least I'm not getting robbed
of my taxes at least on net getting
called a bigot because I don't want six
foot six men who transition to being a
woman last week to play against my
daughter in a basketball game you know
I'm saying to me this is the world we're
living in where people like I'm going
with Trump he's talking looking Kanye
West is in the White House is not racist
and this is where we're living now it's
this this weird society that we have
today where we're there's so much coming
at us and you can't pay attention to all
of us in between all the pop culture and
nonsense and the [ __ ] ice caps are
melting the environment the oceans on
fire everyone's scared of everything
yeah and then on top of that there's all
this political stuff that's going on you
don't have time to pay attention to all
of it if you tell me you're a breast of
all of it I'll tell you're a liar yeah
there's no way let me say something else
as well so I I have a consulting company
and I go around the country and I talk
to every level in the chain of command
including the frontline troops guys that
work construction guys that work gas oil
guys that are out dude linemen that are
output you know at manufacturing
everything those people they're they're
meant most of them they're not out on
the fringe somewhere you know they're
thinking about they're not thinking
about what Trump's and they're actually
thinking about
how they're gonna if they're gonna get
to take a couple days off over the Labor
Day weekend they're getting thinking
about have they had to save enough money
they can get a new truck that's what
they're concerned about they're not
thinking about this they're trying to
live their normal lives and you know
when I was on Ben Shapiro's program and
you know he just came at me like it's so
the all this divisive 'no sand i said
well you live i mean that guy lives at
ground zero for political just
detonation right I said that's not
normal life you're not it's not normal
for everyone else been like yeah I get
it that's what it's like for you but
that's not what it's like for everyone
else so even as the country seemed so
divided you gotta remember the people
that we hear that are so divisive are
the loudmouths
on either end yes and most people aren't
getting in twitter fights about who
whatever they're not they're out trying
to make a living yeah and you know
what's something that you and I think
can relate to is that a lot of these
people don't have anything that brings
them together and I think they should
all join a jujitsu game harder politics
and all that stuff aside the people that
as weird as it seems the people that
choke you and you choke and you get arm
barred by those are your brothers and
sisters and you realize like that the
way we look at politics the way we look
at decisions and you know what you can
agree or disagree on the direction of
the country there's a lack of community
there's a real lack of understanding
that we're supposed to be as the United
States of America we're supposed to be a
giant community we're supposed to be a
family and this this is not how people
are viewing it now we're we're viewing
it like there's this gigantic
battleground that the world is in an
uprising right now and I don't
necessarily think that's true you know
what else to it and I hear you say this
time sometimes and I get what you're
saying but you know you'll say hey this
person's in a cubicle and they hate
their job and they hate their life and
that's like of course most people aren't
like that I get it that there's some
people that end up in jobs that they
don't want to do and I certainly
couldn't see Jill Rogan sitting in a
cubicle or on a manufacturing line but
like I got a factory up in Maine these
people that are up there working they
they love it they're Americans that love
hard work and they're building an
American product and it's like oh okay
this is what I do they're in they'll
stay extra time they'll do whatever
can't they love it and working for you
though they're excited yeah but they're
still working they're still working 9
hours 10 hours 12 hours you know working
on an almond in a factory that's what
they're doing and they love it and you
know what they want they want to have a
good economy they don't want the
government to mess with them it's like
okay that's that's what they want so
it's weird how the social media that we
complain about is is just a it's it's an
amplification of the extremes that's
what it is right and most people aren't
sitting there arguing about what Trump
did or what Hillary Clinton did it's a
gigantic I mean a small giant hugely
small percentage of the population that
is doing all the discourse on Twitter
it's really and if you look there's a
few people that I follow that I don't
follow I just have a bookmark just
because they're just bananas and I'll go
to their page and just look and they're
literally arguing with people about
politics or whatever gender studies and
they're doing it 12 hours a day yeah
they're just at it they're at they're
just frothing at the mouth sweating
palms just phones slipping out of their
hand banging away with their thumb and
they're doing it all day do you think
that or I think that that has something
to do with the fact that they're living
some kind of a decent life I mean as far
as they have food yeah have they have an
iPhone there's noise in the streets and
they're not worried about it yeah and
that's why when we talk about worldwide
problems what I think is what you do the
best possible thing that we can do in
this country to help all these problems
every single problem that we've talked
about build a strong economy yes build a
strong global economy that's the best
thing you can do under build a business
make people have a little bit more money
yes
that's how you get it done and that's
why you know like from my perspective
you know you could get involved in a
business you start a business you move
you help people you build a product that
people want you build a business you
help the economy and that is what
equalizes the world more than anything
else well that's also argument for team
Trump I mean that's Trump's argument
isn't what he's doing is he's boosting
up business in the United States and
whether or not you love him or hate him
what he's doing is having a positive net
effect on the global economy
particularly United States economy and
that's gonna make us stronger I mean
this is whether you love him or hate him
you've got to look at that objectively
and go okay well is there any merit to
what he's saying well I don't understand
economics I don't I just trust people
that study it I don't have the time but
they're saying yes in some ways he's
doing things that benefit business I
think that I think that the the trouble
with the approach that Trump has taken
you know he obviously he's got his
schtick and he's got the things that
he's got his talking points the things
that he says but he is continuing this
mentality when we look at like the trade
war with China and you know the trade
conflict that he started with Canada and
now with different European countries it
is it's the the zero-sum mentality that
in order for us and our economy and our
people to win then the people or the
economies of these other countries have
to suffer and that's what I agree with
what you just said Jocko about you know
building a strong helping grow a strong
global economy gosh shared prosperity I
mean you look at the opportunity that
would provide for peace and less
conflict rather than what we're seeing
it and that this is playing out in real
time with China right now where you see
this trade war that is escalating a
tariff or that's escalating I have met
with farmers in Iowa who are hurting
tremendously because of this trade and
tariff or farm manufacturers small
business owners and the danger of this
continuing to grow and continuing to
escalate an economic war can very easily
turn into a hot war and again we're
talking about a nuclear-armed country
where these ever escalating tensions
push us closer and closer to the brink
of of nuclear catastrophe something
nuclear strategists are saying that we
are we are closer to now than then at
least in a generation I think this is
where the foreign policy that I'm that
I'm putting forward to the American
people that I will lead with is one that
is focused on on engaging with other
countries being that force for good
focusing on cooperation rather than
conflict in every respect being able to
work out yeah we do have trade
differences with China there's no
question about that but being able to do
so in a way
that is not further pushing us closer
and closer to the brink of a hot war and
potentially disastrous can you get into
violence what is the trade what is the
issue with China like what what is Trump
feels like we don't have a fair deal
right that's what he's dated I think
that their I think his his diagnosis I
think is correct I think that's widely
accepted there's you know ongoing trade
imbalance with China and some of the
issues with with IP theft I think those
are the top two that that come to the
forefront the problem is not with the
diagnosis of the issue it is how he's
going about it in a very you know
shoot-from-the-hip kind of way I mean
he's like almost conducting his
negotiations via Twitter he's got
negotiators who were sitting across from
the Chinese and hey okay we're getting
closer to a deal we're gonna work this
out then all of a sudden something goes
out on Twitter they're like whoa man
like the whole thing just changed which
you know it's it's may be funny when
when Trump is putting out something with
Trump Tower in Greenland but when there
are such real consequences to the
day-to-day lives of the American people
and when we're pushing us closer and
closer to the brink of a nuclear
catastrophe escalating these tensions
with countries like China and with
Russia this is I mean it's it's serious
the stakes are very high and and so this
is this is more about how Trump is doing
this in such an irresponsible way that's
creating destabilization and uncertainty
both with our economy and also in our
relationships with other countries
it's everything that made him famous as
a businessman all the brashness all the
shooting from the hip yes the idea that
everybody thought that he was gonna
change when he got in the White House is
hilarious the guy's 73 oh I actually you
can't laugh at me then cuz I thought
well he got elected I was like okay well
this is gonna be interesting to see him
you know kind of become presidential and
and then like whatever one day interview
said another tweet about somebody else
like Rosie O'Donnell's opinion yeah
exactly so crazy but but he's but what
that means is he's unpredictable right
and so he's the guy in the bar that you
look at you're like I'm just gonna give
that guy a little extra clearance cuz he
looks like he's crazy right so I think
that might be what he either thinks he's
doing yeah or
or not but here's the interesting thing
about this okay you know I I don't want
to quote numbers on these things because
I'm not sure what they are right now but
I got a factory been made we make
clothes we make jeans we make jiu-jitsu
jeez all right and all made in America
from the cotton that's grown in America
it's a woven we weave it in our factory
we're doing everything here now there's
things like labor labor is more
expensive in America because we pay our
workers because they're they're awesome
and and so it costs a little bit more to
build the product if you have a Chinese
company that can make a jiu-jitsu key
and they have they're paying their
workers a dollar a day literally and
then they can ship that guy over here
well then they can beat us on the price
now their quality is not as good but
they can beat us on the price and
someone goes okay well I can pay you
know 70 bucks for this Chinese ski or a
hundred bucks for this American geek
okay I'm gonna buy the Chinese one in 70
bucks so and this actually this part
happened again I the details I can't
quite remember but they said hey we're
we're not going to put a tariff on DS
coming into America because they can't
be made here because they can't be made
here and guess what specific things
specific Wow it was like okay can't be
man can't be made here and it was
actually pretty true when was this
I don't know I don't know again I'm I'm
stepping out on a Ledge here gonna have
my buddy Pete come on this product
that's we're late here forever though no
they haven't been they've been made in
Pakistan in China and there was one
company that was making down in Brazil
but we said no actually they can't be
made here and won't make them here and
they put a seven percent tariff on G's
from overseas and so now that kind of
equalizes the price are just a little
bit more expensive but it's made in
American it's higher quality so people
say okay well by Amir are you the only
company in America the only company in
America that is making American
companies they're buying them over 600%
yep wow I didn't know that you know yeah
and what's the key companies just
everybody knows it's called its origin
origin main calm and origin main
original main calm and MA I and EEO
Maine State I was talking to my business
partner I was like I was in the airport
and I go hey man how many people do you
know that train jiu jitsu
and he's like you know like 30 and I go
how many people do you know that that
have a pair of jeans and he said
everybody and I said why don't we make
jeans call because everybody has geez I
could I was in the airport I'm looking
around and you know it was whatever 98
people out of a hundred are wearing
jeans because we're Americans and is
there anything more American to make it
an American company than jeans do you
make jeans with stretch you know yep
yeah it's like you know otherwise you
know making them out of coal no I didn't
know that was your company I think one
of the first podcast I listened to you
from your show at the very end you and I
know Charles we're talking about origin
you're like I'm wearing origin jeans or
this and that about orange I was like
dang they must be pretty good sponsors
what is that boot company that you're
you're involved origin as well and this
is this is the awesome thing about this
is you're from New England well in that
part of in Maine used to be like the
textile and clothing capital of the of
America for sure they made boots they
made bass they made it they made all
these things best boots bass shoes they
made all these textiles up in Maine and
when the trade war started it all went
away it all went away in the 70s in the
80s and they literally took those
machines and ship them overseas to India
and Pakistan and then was my buddy Pete
there was one loom you know what
illumise yeah it's it's this big thing
that's got like eight billion parts to
it he wanted to get a loom cuz he
realized the only way you could get
material for Aggie was to weave it
yourself
otherwise you had to buy it from China
or Pakistan so he goes up to Lewiston
Maine there's a five hundred thousand
square foot abandoned Factory it has a 1
lumen rusty hasn't been used in 30 years
and he fight he found this old-timer
that used to work on the looms him and
his buddies they went and drag this
thing out of this Factory they brought
it into this little factory that he had
built himself out in the middle of the
woods and started taking apart this loom
and reassembling it and started weaving
weaving material and making geese now
that was five years ago we we started
working together we myrrh
together three years ago he had whatever
for employees back there we have 60 now
we're making stuff all the time but this
is when I talk about building the
economy that's what I'm talking about
well and so these areas up in New
England up in Maine that used to be the
so productive well there's not there
wasn't jobs up there and now it's like
oh yeah we got we got jobs and we're
gonna continue to build that company and
just bring manufacturing back to America
so these are things that I think help
when I talk about the global economy you
know who's gonna want American jeans
made it origin in Maine who's gonna want
those people in China people in Japan
they're gonna want these jeans because
they're theirs
they've got soul man they got soul
they're real that's one of the best I've
ever heard that's that's a great place
to start a company like that that's
amazing I think I think that's our as we
as we talk about overall trade policy
and and where we've gone wrong he's
saying you know what happened back in
the 70s and 80s you saw how you know
these these trade these massive trade
deals that were put in place really the
people who benefited most from them were
the the multinational corporations you
are at sorting these jobs and it was
those mom-and-pop those small business
owners and manufacturers who suffered
the most and that's where I think was we
look at you know trade negotiations with
China's we look at some of these trade
deals with countries like India and
others that's where we've got to get
back to rather than just making sure the
largest corporations have a seat at the
trade negotiations tables we've got to
have those small business voices those
small manufacturers and make sure that
our policy is actually helping empower
and strengthen the backbone of our
economy that has been before and that we
need to bring it back to that helps
improve the quality of life for the
people we're working you know working in
Maine manufacturing your jeans and your
gazes and this is and having such great
pride in doing so knowing like hey man
yeah this is maiden arrive senior
packaging says we the people like what
more powerful words are there they're
the first words of our Constitution for
a reason that is what should be at the
forefront of our
are our policies of across across the
board and all these different issues if
the first interest is not we the people
as it has been for so long then we see
what goes wrong and then the consequence
we the people suffer
so the what's going on right now the
consequences of this issue this trade
war with China where it's really hitting
you were saying is there's people in
America that are there selling things to
China yeah well I give you a money I
mean we've heard a lot from like corn
and soybean farmers in Iowa that's the
story that's been in the news a lot we
were at a farmers market and I and I
think it was in Des Moines recently and
we're kind of walking through and
picking up some food and veggies and
stuff like that we stopped at like an an
apple orchard that had a whole table
with all these different beautiful
amazing apples we started talking to the
guy him and his wife run this apple
orchard and he said you know that the
trade and tariffs or with China's hit us
really hard I said wow that's surprising
to me tell me more and he talked about
how I said do you sell do you export
your apples to China and he said no not
at all we sell our apples in Iowa and in
the Midwest and that's at local and
regional customers what happened was the
Apple farms in Washington State selling
Honey Crisp apples that they do export
to China when this trade and tariff war
started they couldn't anymore that
market was completely blocked off to
them and so what they started doing was
shipping their apples to the Midwest at
a fraction of the price that the local
Iowa apple farmer was able to charge to
his clients whether their restaurants or
supermarkets or whatever and he lost
tens of thousands of dollars just over
the last year as a result in this years
that is not looking very good as well as
long as this thing continues it's gonna
it's going to have a disproportionate
negative impact on on his family farm
essentially so you know they're they're
the the obvious kind of
headline-grabbing impacts but then you
look at the downstream you look at you
know a friend of mine as a small
business that he does do business with
China has things that are made in China
and there's a level of uncertain
he doesn't know like how far in ahead he
can plan to purchase how much should he
plan to purchase are things gonna get
better so you should just do a little
bit now and then wait or just the level
of uncertainty and destabilization it's
created I think has been the the most
negative impact on on people here at
home there's some legitimate concerns
too though right like huawei's a weird
one no that one I'm out kind of there
are legitimate concerns yeah for sure
yeah I'm kind of a tech dork and I love
looking at one of the things that China
does particularly well particularly
Huawei is innovation with cell phone
technology I mean they make the most
spectacular cameras they they're like
they were way ahead of the curve on a
lot of different features and they
continue to do that and they were
selling them in America up to a point
and then that cut off and it cut off
with the first time I've ever heard
national security concerns because of a
cell phone company and it just makes you
go well is this real and it's real
cloudy like you talk to people on the
tech side and they said this doesn't
make any sense but then you talk to
people on the intelligence side and they
said this it makes all the sense in the
world like this is a shifty company
that's inexorably tied to the Chinese
government there's no difference between
the government in this company they are
moving they have a long game in this
this long game is provide backdoor
access so that data can be stolen have
that built into systems and they've
caught them doing this before so they're
like we this is you got a finger in the
dam here and this whole thing can come
tumbling down if you don't stop this
company yeah I mean I think some of
those concerns are very valid when
you're when you're talking about Huawei
but I think also just the issue of
building these backdoor entries into our
technology is something that we are very
concerned about both happening here at
home this has been an issue that we've
been dealing with in Congress where
because of provisions that were passed
in the Patriot Act there were loopholes
that have been exploited by some of our
tech companies working with some of our
intelligence agencies to build these
backdoors into their systems
into their programs or into their
hardware which directly violates the
civil liberties and Fourth Amendment
rights for us as Americans and I think
that points to the bigger issue of civil
liberties and privacy and the growing
power that the tech industry has that
we've got to be very very high in my
opinion concerned and careful of and
actually exercising the kind of
oversight and accountability that we
should have been doing frankly a long
time ago tech is a really important
conversation to have with you right now
you're in the middle of this lawsuit
with Google yeah
explain that so the first debate that we
had in this presidential election you
know we had hoped that I would do well
going into it and that people would go
and start their internet search and say
hey who is Tulsi Gabbard I've never
heard of her before and so we went and
got her you know the Google ad set up
got them approved everything was ready
to rock and roll I was the most googled
candidate of the night as I have been
for every debate that I've participated
in the issue was during that first
debate you know what while that peak
period was happening our Google ad
account was suspended by Google with no
explanation whatsoever no like hey there
was nothing like hey you guys screwed up
fixed this that is so sketchy it's so
scary and it and so you know our tech
guys are freaking out they're like man
this is what we were waiting for and now
you guys took our countdown tell us what
we gotta do to get it back up and a we
didn't hear back for a while once we
start hearing back we heard back from
different people with different answers
nothing clear-cut to say you did this
wrong fix this we'll put your account
back nothing and then all of a sudden
you know hours and hours had gone by and
then our account was reinstated without
any explanation about what happened and
you know this is this is bigger than
just the the loss and opportunity that
that my campaign had because this
happened on that night during that peak
period it's a bigger issue about the
power that this corporation has
in Google in interfering essentially in
fair elections and in what kind of
information they are willing to put in
front of people don't they own Boston
Dynamics - does Google on Boston
Dynamics they didn't I sold it you get
extra a double bonus credit for me right
now Tulsi cuz that right there is so
crazy and for you to be like yeah it's
bad for me but it's also bad for the
American people I would have been stuck
it bad for me if they did that and it's
so transparent yeah
very few people talked about it and very
few people know about it exactly that's
what it was so stunning about it it's
like there's people pulling strings who
why not undefined and no investigation
into it until you put out this lawsuit
there's really no way to find out yeah
yeah it started to force that
conversation that was continuing to push
to the forefront
about how particularly with Google and
Facebook the inordinate amount of power
that they have to as we sit and type in
a Google search for whatever or we know
what's popping up on our Facebook feed
they control that I think that we have a
real issue in this country with
advertising in those things in Google
and Facebook a real issue that it's
never really been fully discussed
because those things just sort of came
up out of nowhere
you know we had social networks we had
MySpace and we had you know we didn't
think anything of it and then all of a
sudden not only they hear but they have
this extraordinary amount of influence
yeah
they have algorithm so it's not just
they're putting out what people put out
they have algorithms that figure out
what you're into and then show you that
so if you're just really in a conflict
which most people are they just showing
you conflict all day long and it's
getting everybody riled up so it's
having a direct effect whether it's
planned and coordinated or not it's
having a direct effect on discourse in
this country and I think it's one of the
reasons why what you were talking about
before were you're either with us or
you're against us and it's never been
more hardline than it has been right now
and all of this is because of
advertising money and advertising what
like what are you even selling
all you do you're just a portal to
connect people with each other and
through that you're gaining an insane
amount of influence and an extraordinary
amount of money's being generated and we
never agreed to it right it's just sort
of we just look down we saw the ad what
are they selling oh yeah okay looks like
a nice watch and they were just all of
it and then everybody's just getting
bought and sold and it's happening to a
point now where that is one of the main
town halls one of the main places where
people discuss ideas in the world right
as these social media networks and
they're not getting smaller they're only
getting bigger so they keep growing and
they keep stacking up and whether it's
Google or Facebook or any of the Twitter
and v's the amount of influence they
have is insane and they're just people
right they're just people these are just
regular folks like I know Jack Dorsey
he's a nice guys it's a regular [ __ ]
person the fact that this guy has so
much power this company has so much
power that any of these companies have
so much power we are not ready for this
and this is happening right under our
noses now and it's happening so quickly
and then when something like your Google
situation happens where it's like well
not only you profiting but now you're
[ __ ] pulling strings you're showing
us you're pulling strings yeah and
everybody's like bended whatever they're
interfering with democracy in this weird
sort of semi legal way you know like
that you could just say they violated
policy like what policy what policy did
you violate that they just canceled your
ass if they still have not told us that
doesn't say you violated was being a
viable candidate but one that's saying
hey you guys are too [ __ ] big yeah
I'm gonna break up these monopolies and
provide the kinds of oversight and
accountability that will protect the
consumer that will protect the American
people protect fair and honest discourse
protect freedom of speech that's the
issue and that's and that's the
difference between me and and somebody
like mayor Pete for example other
candidates and he's not the only one but
other candidates who refuse to take a
strong
position in recognizing the threat to
our public discourse and our democracy
that these tech giants have really
within the hands of just a few people
you have I think this is just broke in
the news recently
Mark Zuckerberg who you know people were
taught he's like wanted to run for
president not that long ago and was
seriously considering it and you know
he's trying to start his own
cryptocurrency wants to have his own
currency that he controls like the
amount of power this guy has and that he
wants to continue to grow is is so
dangerous he decided not to run for
president but he and his wife started
emailing a mayor Pete's campaign manager
saying hey here's some guys we think you
should hire for your campaign and so
they hired two of Zuckerberg Facebook
guys who are now working for mayor
Pete's campaign and so they're gonna
have a seat at the table should this guy
get elected
which means Facebook's gonna have a seat
at the table never mind what if he gets
elected when he's got two people at our
inside track at Facebook yeah that show
up there
I don't know if you've ever done
anything with Facebook as far as
advertising but like people that
understand how all that stuff works I'll
talk to him before it's a whole science
behind it so now that they're in there
he should get a big bump across the
board yeah I don't know Mark Zuckerberg
but I don't like the way he drinks water
have you seen that the weirdest little
sips of water I don't I don't trust a
person man woman or non-binary creature
it takes sips of water like that that is
just not the way you drink water we
drink waters like I'm thirsty I'm gonna
have some more that's how you show me
how he did it
well show you will play the video it's
like this he's like he puts this glass
up to his mouth and touches his lips at
the voice like a robot why here we go
watch this look at this he's a robot
pretending to drink watch this what the
[ __ ] is happening here what is happening
here the water didn't boo barely moved
it barely likes slide that Jamie was
able to find that same it has a master
so so to see this from a strategic
perspective
all right do you feel like these moves
like you coming out strong against
Google Facebook saying that you could
break up those types of monopolies
strategically are you thinking right now
well maybe that wasn't the best call
because you know you could have not been
so strong against them and and played
along with them a little bit maybe they
look at you and go through the list that
that Jill went through earlier which is
you're a veteran you're a woman you're a
woman of color you're from Hawaii you've
got this experience congresswoman yeah
congresswoman you got all this stuff
they could look at you go out yeah she's
good we can get her on our side and then
maybe you know increase your chances of
getting elected then you get elected
then you go okay you know what I've
thought about this and guess what we're
not doing it that way and I'm gonna
break you guys up do you think
strategically or is that just your the
type of person you are is like you know
what I'm just gonna I'm just going to
tell the truth from the get-go is that
basically what I tell the truth and call
it straight no matter what and and you
know no matter who who I'm dealing with
because eight that's who I am and the
people are sick and tired of politicians
who play this game and do this political
dance as they're trying to get people
elected and they're like okay well if I
just if I just say this or if I just
kind of cozy up to these people or these
interests they can help me get elected
and then when I win then I'm gonna do
the right thing well guess what as when
you win all of you okay I've got to win
the next reelection that means I need
more money from Wall Street I need more
money from Google I need more money from
these guys so I can't say anything to
piss them off just yet I'm gonna wait
until I get reelected then that's when
I'm really gonna start to do the right
thing and and I think people across
party lines are sick and tired of the
same old politicians who say one thing
and do another and instead are looking
for real leadership it just seems like
there's a tipping point that we all have
to reach before that actually happens I
don't know if we're there yet it's kind
of like you know when I was on your
podcast for the first time Joe and you
told me to start a podcast at that time
I don't know if you know this or not it
was in it was 2015 the stats were that
17% of America were listening to
podcasts
and now it's something like 78 percent
in four years just totally different but
when you talk about Tulsi having a
podcast which you absolutely should him
by the way all you need to do is go and
do a question-and-answer Town Hall of
people have somebody record it splice it
up to a good stuff and put that out 20
minutes long people start to learn how
you are yes but my point is that that
change happened and right now you know
Joe Rogan has like the most powerful
voice in media in in a very short period
of time but five years ago he didn't you
know five years ago it'd be like oh you
want to sell a book you better go on the
big network nowadays oh you want to sell
a book you try and get on Joe Rogan and
Eaton peddle some book for you or get
your product out there or help your
campaign we're like at that tipping
point politically it seems right now and
yeah just what is it gonna take to push
people over the edge that's the question
I think that what we saw happen in in
I think pointed to that tipping point
and I believe that that we are here
because you know I these are
conversations that we're having in town
hall meetings in different parts of the
country again where we're building this
coalition of Americans who are most
interested in putting our country first
who are willing to disagree without
being disagreeable but understand we got
to treat each other with respect and
stand united around the principles and
freedoms that bring us together focusing
on We the People putting the interests
of the people first and foremost and and
I would say that the vast majority of
Americans have have put up with the
same-old same-old for so long and are
sick and tired of this pay-to-play
culture in Washington of the political
corruption that exists of the you know
big-money special interests who
influence the decisions that leaders are
making the benefit them instead of the
people that they're looking for a leader
that says what they mean and mean what
they say and who will back that up with
action and I think that's where our
opportunity that swear we're seeing you
know support growing from my campaign
the more people hear about who I am the
background and experience that I bring
to this job and and that I that I am
willing to take
a stand to speak the truth for the
people even against some of the most
powerful interests honestly our biggest
challenge is getting in front of you
because most people in the country still
don't know who I am or you have people
who maybe have heard about me but
they've gotten the the corporate media
narrative but they're Tulsi curious
they're Tulsi curious and I'm really
that's a good way to put it so that's
really where our our effort is is
focused now New Hampshire's voting and
less than a hundred days and so you know
we're asking for support from people to
make contribution to my campaign tolls
literally well see 2020 dot-com
literally getting this support will make
the difference for us to be able to
bypass this corporate media narrative
and actually communicate directly
directly to voters directly to people no
one better than you knows that these
tech companies have this extraordinary
amount of power and that it's it's just
no one anticipated it it came out of
nowhere what do you think could be done
to ensure that people have a voice and
that this voice is not being manipulated
because of financial interests or
political interests and this is where
we're at today that this these companies
like it or not they don't have to abide
by the First Amendment that's not what
they do they can decide we're gonna ban
you based on your political leanings
based I mean there's a famous case out
of Canada where a woman was eight having
and she's a you know what a turf is it's
a trans exclusionary radical feminists
that's never heard that the radical
feminists who don't believe that
transgender women should be involved in
women's issues and that they shouldn't
be able to vote on women's issues and
she was in an argument on Twitter her
name is Megan Murphy and she said a man
is never a woman Twitter told her you
got to take that down so she's a bit
feisty she took it down took a
screenshot put it back up with a
screenshot she's like okay I took it
down there it is again though and
they've banned her for life Wow for life
so it's something like that where you
can't even have opinions on things that
are controversial without being removed
from the discourse we have a real
problem with that yeah that's a giant
problem this is just one social thing
that's a hot button
shoot right now and whether or not it'll
stay with her it's just a fad or it'll
go away or it'll be normalized we don't
know but the fact that you don't have
the First Amendment protecting people
from a legitimate opinion that's
actually based on you know whether you
like it or not biological science this
is this is a very we're in a very
strange time that a company and I just
use this as an example because you're
talking about something where it's
biologically clear that she's correct
whether or not you socially think that
people should be treated how they want
to be treated and use the pronouns thing
I agree with that yeah but you're
talking about someone who's saying
something that's biologically correct so
we have a we have a problem we're at a
we're at a fork in the road and we have
to figure out how the hell this gets
handled because if just social trends
like this can dictate whether or not a
person is removed from the conversation
forever we've got a generator there's no
other options no other alternative
platform yes that you can participate in
and that's just one example of the
thousands and thousands of examples of
people that are removed from
conversations based on their political
leanings their ideologies and and
meanwhile there is just unlimited
hardcore pornography on Twitter which is
perfectly okay yeah but we can't say
that about whatever that situation is we
understand it as well Oh James is on
Twitter
what's the Solaris and also I think that
kind of thing is the kind of thing that
gets a backlash from moderate people
absolutely a moderate person sitting in
Nebraska is like well who am i voting
for well these people are bad that
they're against this whole idea okay
looks like Trump is on my side yeah how
do you reduce that and that see this
this idea that you can deep platform
people and somehow know that weakens the
position that you don't agree with it's
the opposite the opposite happens you
pump up the only hope that they have of
getting their side of the story out
there their side of the story is going
to be represented by Trump and Trump
supporters and I don't know what the
president can or can't do to sort of
enforce some sort of I mean we obviously
have a new situation when it comes to
communication in this country with
social media and tech companies
yes it's very new and it's really it's
it's only the last couple of decades
it's even been a thing and now it's one
of the
biggest things when income in terms of
discourse and how people communicate and
how people form opinions about things
that's a tremendous influence on our
culture yeah and the fact that this
isn't protected by the First Amendment
we have a very strange new force in our
country when it comes to discourse and I
think laws need to be formed that we
need to have some sort of parameters
that you mean there's laws on virtually
everything and virtually everything that
has massive influence over the way it
affects our country and that's one where
there isn't really there's no
independent companies and there they're
not there they can do whatever they want
yeah essentially yeah I mean no it's
it's limitless I think I agree with you
I think this is I agree with you both
with regards to the tech companies but
also this bigger kind of culture war
that's happened here in our country this
canceled culture that exists that I
think it I mean it does it threatens the
kind of of freedom of speech and and
discourse and I think we've celebrated
in this country for so long where this
is the country yeah where you can stand
up and say what you believe no matter
how terrible I may think it is or how
strongly I may disagree with it you know
people like us are willing to lay our
life down for your right to do that
I think that's that's what is at risk
here with this this culture this this
cancel culture it's having such a
chilling effect where people are maybe
afraid to say something that may be seen
as controversial to some because they
will get cancelled and and in summer and
in some cases you've seen how people's
especially if you're a public figure
your whole career can be just like gone
finished canceled cultures real simple
everyone now has a rock and there's a
big window someone throws a rock at that
window and you're like well [ __ ]
throw a my rug - and that's what happens
people just whether or not they have a
strong opinion of something or not they
just decide that's the spot we're
throwing the rocks right and they just
chucked the rocks and then they feel
like they have some sort of a part you
know if a politician gets taken down
they're like look I helped look at my
Twitter feed my Twitter feeds filled
with calling that guy pieces I was the
first one yeah the first one that did it
I think that that you know you mentioned
was it happened
Kamala Harris was shoot she'd like
launched a petition or publicly was
calling for Twitter to delete president
Trump's account yeah and she really
really made a big deal out of this did a
whole media tour like all this is called
out Elizabeth Warren all this stuff I
was asked about it by a reporter shortly
after she had made this announcement I
did not even heard of it like what do
you think about Kamala Harris calling on
Twitter to cancel Trump's Twitter
account I said well you know I disagree
with not everything a lot of what Trump
says but freedom of speech freedom of
speech so no I completely disagree with
her and the response from her campaign
spokesperson no kidding tulsi gabbard
echoes fox news talking points freedom
of fox news is saying oh well what about
freedom of speech by the way Richard
Spencer loves her but that's like this
is where we're at like just saying hey
freedom of speech you're the president
with you're the president United States
or you're the guy sweeping the floor in
the White House I will stand up and
fight for your freedom of speech I may
disagree and I may disagree publicly and
strongly but we've got it we've got to
draw the line here for freedom of speech
and being able to have this dialogue in
discourse where we can and I think that
we should debate strongly and maybe
passionately about some of these issues
not seeing that as a bad thing I mean
that's been the strength of our country
it'll be interesting you know from a
free market perspective if at some point
somebody comes out with a social media
platform that is really truly free
speech rolls theirs thinks buck and run
around right now
gabs yeah it'll just be yeah and but
people have told me Tech friends of mine
that say they say that immediately turns
into what is it for Shan an H and it
just immediately goes into the gutter
it's in the open sue I mean it's just
like have you ever seen those pipes that
pump sewage into the ocean I mean and
it's not the fault of the social media
company so the companies like gab
they're committed to free speech and
what they're trying to do is let it just
let it all work itself out and
by the Constitution don't Doc's anybody
don't give up anybody's addressed right
and threaten anybody or do any harm and
just talk crazy and do it anonymously
and that's what a lot of people are
doing and but it's it's very difficult
for even the people that felt like they
were deep platformed or their voice
wasn't being able to be heard they don't
want to join in to this crazy [ __ ]
because because of 4chan all this
savages they're just trying to post
pictures of their dinner it's so nuts I
mean look I mean even posting pictures
of your dinner I mean you get you do
that on Instagram and if it's a dead
deer or something like that you're your
risk of getting your picture taken down
it's the amount of power that's being
exhibited by these social media
companies again no one anticipated this
what could be done what do you think
could be done like say you you get you
become president what would you do so I
think there's there's two things here
that we've talked about the freedom of
speech the control over information I
think part and parcel to that that we
didn't really talk much about is how
much of our private information these
tech companies have and what they're
doing with it maybe without us even
knowing about how that's that's helping
to drive up their profits I think it's
it's both of those components you've got
to be concerned about number one is we
look at our antitrust laws that exist in
this country for the protection of the
consumer against any giant monopolies
from coming in and being a position to
abuse their power and apply those laws
to these tech giants I think the fact
that Facebook owns obviously Facebook
Instagram and whatsapp I don't think
that I think that is the definition of a
monopoly across platforms that many of
us use because there isn't really a
legitimate alternative option available
to us so I think that's the first thing
and looking at breaking up these these
monopolies
I think Facebook's co-founder took Chris
Hayes I think is his name I think he
wrote I think very compelling argument
against Facebook monopoly saying they
have gotten way too powerful they should
not have been able to buy these other
companies and the second thing is
Congress actually digging down
and passing laws that provide actual
oversight and a level of accountability
to ensure that our freedom of speech and
our freedom to access information is not
impeded by these tech giants whether
it's for their own profits or to pursue
their own political interests they face
they face there's people inside of
Twitter that are like Jack Dorsey
believes and at least according to what
he's told me that Twitter should be like
a town hall where everyone should be
able to have access but he faces
resistance that inside the actual
company that he's a CEO of there's so
many people that don't think that that's
the way it should be and they think that
they have a political or a social
obligation to limit certain voices
because those voices radicalize young
people like what do you say to those
people I mean with without knowing
examples of what they're citing here's
the thing is is what they may view is
radicalizing young people because of the
ideology that they as individuals may
hold on to may be seen in the opposite
way by people who hold a different
political ideology you know I think this
is something that that that we're seeing
happening offline as well you know
whether it's in in college campuses or
in other places where both sides view
the other side as indoctrinating young
people are indoctrinating people with
their ideology look at Fox News and
MSNBC they are both pushing opposing
narratives on you know news happenings
of the day or whatever's happening in
Washington there you watch the exact
same thing happened you know the killing
of Baghdady you saw a very different
bias in the news the most watched
entities you see the Washington Post
explain tell people what they saw did
they put a story up that's a I forget
what the court was for the awesomest
alaric religiously
scholar yeah Wow yes what's the word a
store what does that word astute no
religious scholar forget what word they
used to describe him just try to find
out with this I think it's a stir
religious scholar I was like what that
guy yeah yeah like how can you
that's just insanity yeah but how does
that in serve man how does that get
through how does I mean how does someone
in the Washington Post go okay
I like what you did there yes that you
can't even fathom yeah was that head of
Isis yeah exactly
there it is a stirrer how do you say
that word I saw students dear I never
say that word I just read it yeah that's
the first time in my whole life 52 years
of age I've said it out loud
religious scholar at helm of its Islamic
state dies at 48 what in the [ __ ] Wow
religious Scott well at least when you
zoom in on his eyes there you can tell
he's completely insane yeah zoom in on
that Jamie let me get a zoom why yeah
whoa Jesus Christ he got ahold of Trump
sudafed look at that title yeah it's so
bananas yeah it is it's crazy
that's as Tulsa just pointed out that's
someone driving a narrative right yeah
that's someone driving there because
somebody that doesn't understand this
that's their first glimpse of of this
reality in their glimpse of this reality
is that this guy was an austere
religious leader what is the actual
definition of austere let's let's pull
that up because I want to find out how
hilarious this really is because I think
it's really hilarious which by the way
it's Jamie he's doing that Washington
Post owned by oh here we go severe or
strict in manner attitude or appearance
an austere man with a rigidly
puritanical outlook too nice this guy
was a Puritan as far as they're
concerned yeah
Puritan piece of [ __ ] having an
extremely plain and simple style or
appearance unadorned okay he's dressed
like a genie he's living in a hole in
the ground and he's running Isis you
people are
out of your month offensive it's so
strange I mean there's real monsters in
this world and when you add a bunch of
words to a description of a real monster
that make that person seem like they're
a contributor to culture it's just and
that's what it seems religious scholar
oh he's a religious scholar must be a
good guys helping people just so happen
to me well he saw people's heads off
he's thrown gay people off the top of
buildings right because they don't agree
with his quote unquote religious
scholarly beliefs such a strange choice
the fact that that's a mainstream
publication a huge newspaper and that is
that somehow or another slipped through
the net like what the headline like that
front page that's not slipping through
the net
you know it's nuts that's planned but to
someone like you
who's actually had to go over there and
risk your life to fight guys like that
how sick does that make you to just read
that it's awful for a couple reasons
obviously it's awful for the kind of
straightforward reason that you realize
that people are learning the wrong thing
they're gonna understand this in in the
wrong way that's one part of it but the
other part of is that there's someone
that wrote that headline yeah you know
someone that wrote someone that has a
position of influence in the world that
wrote that headline and said yeah this
guy's an austere religious leader
scholar
there's a guy I forget his name he's uh
he's a famous Muslim commentator who's
online but he attacked that so viciously
and talked about what a piece of garbage
that guy actually was and how awful he
is and how this goes against everything
that a modern Muslim feels and thinks
yeah and that this have this person
represent and to say a religious scholar
is so deeply offensive and that's
fantastic I wish I could remember that
guy's name who did it met Mehdi ma DHI
but this is the Washington Post I mean
this isn't like someone's blog on
tinder or something or whatever wherever
you have blogs these days it's this is a
huge mainstream publication and it just
the the distorting of narratives is such
a strange factor in today's culture that
this we don't have a Walter Cronkite
giving us the straightforward news every
day on the air with no lean or slant and
just give you the facts we don't have
that we don't have what we thought of as
you know a top level newspaper from 1980
or whatever where they were doing real
journalism trying to break down the
story in a way that you could understand
while you're drinking your coffee trying
to haze the world blowing up let me see
what's going on here yeah my dad pointed
out to me you know you were talking
about there's nothing that unifies us
anymore
and you're like hey everyone changing
Jitsu I obviously agree with that but
well my dad was telling me that in the
60s and the 70s there was one unifying
thing that everybody did which is
watched Walter Cronkite on the news and
so when you showed up to work the next
day everyone had heard the same
narrative and they and they could have
disagreed on it but they all had kind of
the same basic fundamental facts and so
now we actually have people going home
and I'm gonna jump into my bubble over
here and watch Fox News and you're gonna
get jumped into your bubble over there
and watch MSNBC and like how do you even
communicate with each other yeah yeah we
don't we have so many choices but so few
paths I was well I was I was I caught
some Rachel Maddow one time and I'd
never watched her before so I was like
okay I'm gonna watch her and I was like
wow it's just completely different
completely different then what I I would
see on Fox News completely different and
I'm thinking myself wow this is hard too
hard to imagine and you've seen the
clips of when Trump won of all the the
compilation of everyone's reaction Paul
did all the liberal reaction they were
but on the news yes I mean this does
does MSNBC they don't claim to be like
you know nonpartisan at all do they or
our news for that matter I think I think
they don't have to it's just they are
MSNBC they don't have to have a
directive they just say everyone knows
it's like we there's there's an
understanding when you
going they're either going to hate view
like you're either a Republican is going
there to see what these silly liberals
are up to or you're one of the converted
and she's preaching to the choir I think
what one interesting proof point of this
is I think a poll came out yesterday on
where the American people stand on
impeachment and something like 75 80
percent of Fox viewers oppose
impeachment and 75 80 percent of NBC
MSNBC viewers support impeachment and
they're covering the very same
impeachment inquiry and hearings and we
know witness testimony and and all of
that I don't think people even
understand what that all means and
whether or not it even has a chance of
happening you know base no I don't think
I don't think people do either they
don't they just it seems like some fun
talking point some gotcha thing where
they've got them you know Ukraine got
him we got him we got him this time
stormy Daniels didn't stick but this one
this one's gonna say yeah hey you know
you think yourself if stormy Daniels
didn't stick and just try and work with
the guy at that point I'm like okay you
know what he's Teflon we're just need to
move on and move forward there's a
hilarious girl I don't know who she is
then I send you that video with the
girls getting people to get pumped up
about impeachment and she's got like
like rainbow colored hair and she looks
like a liberal I think she even has one
of those pink kitty cat hats on and and
she gets them she's like Pro impeach
they like yeah impeach and [ __ ] a
peach but she goes yay president pence
yeah yeah she's like president picks her
so if he gets impeached then we get
president pence and they like maybe we
should just like let this play probably
just let him finish his term but it is
it is hilarious it's hilarious because P
it's a sport it's it's it's basically
replacing it's for it's a sport for
people don't like football it's like
their their idea of who's winning or
losing this game is very personal and
they feel like their team got killed in
2016 and they'll have to come back and
kick ass in 2020 and that's what's going
on and everything they can get at them
well not not only that I mean that
it's that but then you've got some folks
who some some Democrat leaders and in
Washington who are saying well you know
we need to get rid of Trump through
impeachment to protect ourselves from
possibly losing the election in 2020
which i think is just like a an open and
you know admit all of well we don't
think that we can actually beat him at
the ballot box so we're trying to use
this political maneuver in order to get
rid of him even though it's it's highly
unlikely that even if the house does
vote to impeach which isn't fully clear
at this point but even if that were to
happen the Senate is not going to
convince at twenty it's highly unlikely
the Senate is going to convince twenty
Republicans to vote with every Democrat
to to actually physically kick Trump out
of office and that this is why I mean
I've always maintained that you know
look I look forward to beating Donald
Trump at the ballot box where the
American people can unequivocally let
their voices be heard saying nope we're
done with the leadership and and all
that Trump brought to office and we're
choosing to go in a new direction have
you thought about what kind of nickname
he'll have for you because you know he's
gonna come up with a nickname yeah did
you see how they they played you on
Saturday live I did was what I went on
there because I said I got to see what
they did to her and I was really curious
about what they were gonna do how they
were gonna make you out and he made you
out to be like this super evil person
yes I got a kick out of it no it's funny
it's it's a it's a it's a super short
clip but basically they're like there is
a villain amongst all of these
candidates and that villain is toll see
yeah he strikes fear into the heart of
every other person up here I have
something like that like a despicable me
type cartoon villain they portrayed me
as like a karela davila the thing is I
was thinking as it was playing out out
they don't show you for a while and I go
they're not even in and put her in here
I was like they're not even they're not
even gonna put her in here they big you
know Clinton got to her and said oh I
don't want any airtime at all
it's just so interesting to me that they
it's it's so clear that you're a vibrant
candidate but that they don't want to
get behind you yeah but yet they do want
to get behind Joe Biden who can barely
get through a sentence that poor guy is
falling but someone needs to give that
guy like growth hormone steroids like
kale shakes fat steaks like bro you need
to take some time off we need to get you
in a hyperbaric chamber you don't have
any energy yeah especially because
Donald Trump has energy yes and he goes
on stage for an hour and a half I had a
rally with no teleprompter no 30,000
people 33 men no drink no no bathroom
break he's just up there going he's like
an animal up there and it fuels him and
then you meanwhile you're looking at
Biden and you're like this how is this
even gonna work out his teeth are
literally falling out against these four
peoples names wrong do they want to win
or don't they think that is the question
like they don't want to win with someone
they can't control exactly you know it's
like the first UFC
you know they had hoist fight in the
first UFC because it couldn't control
Hickson no exits the family champions
like Dixon's gonna do whatever the [ __ ]
Hickson wants that I have so Horry it
was like well if hoist loses they're
gonna go with Hicks for now let's get us
in there he couldn't control the exit
yeah if you wanted to show what
jiu-jitsu could do everyone on earth
that knew jiu-jitsu knew Hicks and
Gracie was the baddest man on the planet
how do you navigate this Tulsi it seems
like the it seems like okay if you want
to get the Democratic nomination you've
got to be pretty far to the left right
but if you want to actually win the
presidency then you've got to be more
moderate so that seems like a tough
little thing to try and get through as
well I think that that is the
conventional so-called wisdom that just
isn't true anymore I think this is what
you know you hear a lot of the political
pundits talking to who's far left to
centrist moderate who's this this that I
think what's what's proving to be true
is it's more about you know who is who
is who's the establishment candidate
versus who is anti-establishment and
that you know I I don't fit into any one
of those boxes
because I look at every issue based on
its merits I'll look at the substance of
the issue look at the arguments for and
against and go with the approach that I
think this is a radical idea that's the
thing like these people they're like oh
my god we can't figure her out cuz she
doesn't have any of these labels but but
that is where the vast majority the
American people are you have these these
extremes on the fringes who are all
about these you know purity tests where
you are either with me on every single
issue or you're done you're finished
you're unacceptable but the vast
majority of Americans again they're
looking at what is real leadership real
leadership whether you're talking about
the guy who's working in the
manufacturing warehouse you're talking
about a blue-collar worker you're
looking at okay here's here's the here's
the issues that keep most people up at
night you know you want to make sure
that if your kid is sick they're gonna
be they're gonna be able to get the
health care they need you want to make
sure you have a roof over your family's
head they're there basic things
approaching them in a way that is
pragmatical
pragmatic common-sense and solutions
oriented is not only the right thing to
do I think it's the thing that makes it
so you don't have to say well in the
primary I'm only going to talk to
Democrats and the most radical Nick and
extreme among them and then I'm totally
gonna flip the script and then speak to
the whole country after I win the
primary election that's that's
ridiculous this is why you know I'll go
on Fox News MSNBC CNN and I'm delivering
the exact same message to people and
we're building and growing supporting
people who watch those three different
channels who are actually listening like
me like she makes sense
like she's not crazy she's not spouting
some party talking point she's not you
know going down a radical path just to
appeal to the the Twitter winds that are
blowing one way or the other it's just
about hey let's do what's what's best
let's do its best for the people and for
the country I'm stunned by the blow back
to for you going on Fox News the people
actually upset that they do not think
that you should grace this the the Fox
News screens yeah the
you you're doing a disservice to your
party yeah which is interesting while I
get the same stuff and because I go on
Fox News and why do I go on Fox News Fox
News invites me onto Fox News you know
who's never invited me on MSNBC and
again as you pointed out earlier like
it's pretty hard to pin me down
politically right yeah and I'm not one
to sit there and try and make radical
statements to try and get more you know
likes on a Twitter thing you don't do
that okay yeah I don't it's like oh I'm
here trying to make some points about
the way you know most of what I talk
about is about leadership yeah it's like
oh because of what we're doing as human
beings is we're leading other people
whether it's just your family or whether
it's your business or whatever or its
troops out in the field
so yeah it's weird that you would get
attacked for going on Fox News when
actually anybody that looks at that from
a strategic view would think oh she's
actually accepted by by this this
right-wing news organization maybe she
could get some other you know moderate
conservative votes maybe we should think
about bringing her as a candidate
because she could win well not only that
what's wrong with going on stage or
going on camera with someone that you
oppose someone you disagree with and
having a dialogue about what you
disagree with right that's the weird
thing about this cancel culture this is
strange time we're living and you're not
even supposed to communicate with people
about ideas that you disagree on yeah
resizing you but being on Tucker Carlson
shown particularly yeah and that's I was
gonna say you know yeah it's one thing
to say okay you're gonna go on fox news
and you know tussle with sean hannity
about things you disagree on but I think
what they see is more dangerous is
finding areas where you actually do
agree right and that's you know on
Tucker Carlson I have a platform to be
able to speak to millions of people
across the country about the kind of
leadership that I bring in the area of
foreign policy what I would do here in
this country what I would do there in
that country if I were president today
and I have the opportunity to deliver
that message directly to people's living
rooms or offices or wherever they are
and you know I think in some of these
areas Tucker Tucker and I will disagree
on a whole host of things but on some of
these issues of foreign policy he'll say
yeah I
agree with you and I think when you look
at this this canceled culture how you
know I was attacked on the debate stage
for going on Fox News how do you think
you're gonna lead this country all
Americans if you're completely not only
shutting out and not willing to talk to
half the country that watches Fox News
but you're in fact disrespecting and
dismissing them just because they may
disagree with you or they watch a
different news channel than you do I
think that's the bigger issue here is
yeah you know there's a political
consequence you're never gonna be able
to have a dialogue with what to speak of
win support from people who you treat
like garbage who you disrespect you call
names who you call deplorable but how do
you expect to lead as the president of
every single American in this country
when you've thrown half of them away and
saying you know what I actually don't
care about you I only care about people
who I agree with that's that's to me the
the worst part about all of this does uh
that deplorable thing it was a big hit
and then you also remember when Mitt
Romney said hey there's 47% of the
country that there's no way vote for him
so we just need to forget about them
yeah exactly to those two things
completely divided and sent people to
vote for the opposing candidate like you
didn't call me deplorable oh really
watch this I'm voting for gonna ignore
me or you're just dismissing my vote
doesn't matter I think also it speaks to
what both people have that it's
distasteful that they're calculated and
one of the things that I do appreciate
you about you is that I think you're not
I think the way you view things is you
would far rather speak your mind and be
truthful and have real legitimate
opinions on things rather than have some
weird slimy sort of shifty take that's
been created by a bunch of people that
think that this is going to be the right
thing that you could say that's gonna in
you know and get youse a little closer
in the polls and move you this way and
move the needle that way that that
shifty style of politics I really feel
is dead I just I just don't think you
can do it that way
anymore I think people because of the
open access to information that people
have today in the the way that people
can communicate and and find out
information I just don't think we want
to buy that shifty politician talk
anymore I think we're done with it I
think we realize it's antiquated it's
it's never served us it sucks and it
just it just gives you the same thing
every time you get someone who gets into
office and they do completely different
things and what they said they were
going to do before they got in yeah
that's even you know I thought about all
the people are they hurt deployables
they hurt 47% and that's bad but yeah
you're right what it really made people
think is oh behind the scenes
you're totally different than you are
when you're standing on stage shifty I
know what you're liking I'm not voting
for you yeah you manipulative you know
you're following this you know you're
following whether it's polls or you're
following these these groups that are
going out and trying to figure out which
way the tide is turning on social media
I mean there's so many groups now and so
many companies that are just just
looking at data online and opinions and
then they give this data to people that
are trying to influence folks and they
lean one way or another and they try to
manipulate their message in order to
have a more favorable rating and it's so
slimy and it's also the the kind of
hypocrisy of this whole thing is these
are people who are asking to lead the
most powerful nation in the world yes
and yet they are not leaders at all
they're followers have you given any
consideration to the fact that this is
basically an impossible job that
everybody who gets in their ages 150
years except Trump he doesn't seem to
age at all he looks great for I mean
look like [ __ ] when he got it but he
looks exactly the same I mean you would
think you look like a skeleton right now
he'd be a corpse but know what looks
like it's not even it's like he eats a
lot of fast food I hear rolling off his
back whatever it is there's a lesson to
be learned he should give an he really
should give a class on not giving a [ __ ]
and like how it oh yeah he's got a
master's degree in that
you could say you don't give a [ __ ] but
that's when the whole world is angry at
you like half the world maybe more than
half the world because it's half of
America and then who knows what
percentage of the rest of the world is
upset at you not a lot of supporters
internationally right yeah it just keeps
moving but have you given any
consideration to that this is a job that
almost no one really nails no one gets
out after four years or eight years and
like boom no one all these visual images
in my mind I mean nobody gets out go
bomb you did it there's half the people
gonna hate you no matter what in this
this legit there's a legit argument that
it's a ridiculous position that to have
one alpha chimp dominate the entire clan
in 2019 when there's 320 million of us
it seems insane it doesn't seem like you
really can pay attention to everything
whether it's the economy the environment
or foreign policy or all the social
issues is so much going on how can one
person really have that job so the first
thing I'll say is that if you're going
into this to be popular or to have
everybody love you then you should not
be president at all that's why I'm never
going to be President when we get them
excited I think I think that's the most
important thing that's the problem that
we see in a lot of our politics is and
and what we're seeing on Twitter is
people are putting stuff out for what
they think will get the most likes or
will get the most retweets rather than
putting out what they believe in or
what's true or or what what's actually
really really important I think that's
the first thing about how I would govern
and lead as president about continuing
what I've always done which is actually
just focusing on hey let's let's do the
best job we can do to deliver the best
result for the American people none of
us are perfect and won't always get it
perfectly right
all the time I think understanding that
we have often forgotten these days we
have three co-equal branches of
government so the president alone in the
executive branch does not have absolute
or ultimate power over our government or
over making decisions that impact the
lives of Americans across this country I
think our our founders set up our
government with this in mind that we
left the monarchy for a reason so that
we don't have one person with absolute
power but instead we have a president a
commander-in-chief who is leading our
country working with the United States
Congress the house in the Senate which
is made up of people who are elected
from their communities or friend from
their states to be able to form and
shape the policies that do impact the
lives of people in this country so that
these decisions are not being made
within a vacuum by one single individual
but instead by a representative form of
government with the judiciary branch as
the check and balance to say hey this
this one does not fall in line with the
Constitution of the United States we're
gonna throw that one out making sure
that these elected leaders you know are
doing the right thing for the people so
I think I think the the opportunity
that's here and I think what's necessary
is having a president who leads with the
best interests of the people in mind
take seriously the principles enshrined
within our Constitution does not abuse
that executive power which is something
that we've seen growing in one
consecutive administration after another
crossing both party lines but instead
really take seriously that oath that we
all take that we took as a member of
Congress that we took in the military
that the president takes to uphold and
defend our Constitution against all
enemies foreign and domestic
well set yeah and I think you know Tulsi
is a military person as well and when
you go and you do the best you can and
you make the decisions for the right you
make the you make the decisions for the
right reasons which aren't necessarily
going to turn out right sometimes you
make decisions and they don't turn out
okay but you had the right intentions
you tried to right do the right thing it
didn't go the way you wanted it to you
don't point your fingers or blame
anybody else you say okay here's here's
the mistake I made here's we're gonna do
to fix it and at the end of the day you
can walk away and say okay well I know
that I did the best I could with the
right intentions and generally just like
you were talking about people being able
to see through when someone's lying
behind says people see you know what
they're trying to do the best job they
had the right intentions in mind and and
I think you I think you actually could
walk away from the job not saying I did
a great job nailed it as Joe Rogan would
say but but to walk away and with your
head held high and be able to say yeah I
did the best I could do
I made some good decisions I made some
bad decisions I tried to get us on the
right path I tried to support the
principles that I believe this country
is based on and you move forward I think
that's completely doable yeah do you
have a long-term idea like if if you
don't win in 2020 are you gonna stick
around for 2024 like how what is what
are your thoughts on that I'm focused on
2020 and then once that passes whether
you win or not then you think about the
few access so you're only 38 right yeah
I don't buy that gray hair either I
think it's fake I think you said like a
streak just a cool-looking streak no
it's right no yeah you're gonna keep it
if the whole thing goes gray so I don't
know far hold you to that yeah no no I I
started to go gray during my first
deployment and so I decided to keep it
just as a physical reminder of those we
lost and the price that so many people
paid if you win will you be the youngest
person ever to be president or where
there's some weirdos in the 1700's no I
will be um actually I believe I'll be
the youngest yeah youngest and a woman
pretty badass yeah double first and you
would think that a lot of people would
be really excited about that
instead of just attacking you yeah well
again it just shows you how people are
so committed to the machine and you're
one of the best examples of that I think
because there's so much exciting about
what you're saying there's so much that
resonates as being honest and
straightforward and well-thought-out
Newlands nuanced and balanced and yet
still so much resistance but I think the
machine is strong and the machine knows
that it doesn't really have a grip on
you they don't and they never will and I
think that you mentioned earlier I think
that's that's creating fear and concern
I just think it's important to point out
that the difference and we talked about
the people who are concerned about this
it is the people whose power is built
off of you know they've built this
foundation of power based on the status
quo based on continuing this narrative
that benefits the very few you know the
most rich the most powerful the people
who can purchase this influence in
Washington as opposed to you know the
vast majority of people in this country
unfortunately whose voices are not being
heard in Washington whose concerns are
not being met by and large and who exist
outside of this this bubble of
corruption within Washington and who
were looking for a leader who's gonna
hear their voices and amplify them and
serve their interest and I think that's
where again you know we've got great
opportunity and responsibility to to
reach those people all across this
country and let them know who I am and
to hear my message so they know that
there there is a choice that they do
have a choice between more of the same
old same old more of the pay-to-play
corruption that that exists in
Washington more of the perpetuation of
the same foreign policy of intervention
and Missouri regime change that's failed
us and cost us so much versus fresh
leadership with a new approach that puts
our are the interests of our country and
peace and security at the forefront of
the decisions that are being made I
think this is an interesting time too
because it's one of the first times that
I can remember
politicians that are running for
president are pushing back against the
media machine like Andrew yang recently
said I'm not going to go on and MSNBC
unless they apologize publicly for a
lack of representation I mean they
didn't get it give him a chance to talk
and they treated meanwhile there's a
giant well of support behind him as well
yeah yeah yeah people what people are
are seeing through the you know the the
facade that is presented by the
corporate media and I think finding the
power in our voices on you know through
alternative media new media social media
and and and I think that's that's what
we're seeing with people hey if they're
given my campaign $5 or you know $10 a
month like there's so much power that is
that is uh I think people are
discovering within their own voices that
can that that really is the only thing
that can overcome the obstacles that the
political and media establishment are
placing before us and before the people
in having their voices heard who is an
elite now it's still Biden right and
behind Biden is Elizabeth Warren is that
what the ideas it seems like it it seems
like I think when you look at some of
these polls I think that's the other
thing is is they most often represent
who is most well known in the country
whose most famous rather than who
actually has the most support and
Elizabeth Warren wasn't she a Republican
for a long time yeah when did she not be
one just become a Democrat I may be
wrong but I want to say she was in her
40s maybe early fifty something like
that do you get a chance to talk to
these people
briefly I mean it's it's usually in
passing at different campaign events or
before the debate or something like that
I I know Bernie Sanders best obviously
no no a few of the others who have I've
worked with in the Senate in Congress on
different issues Andrew Andrew Young
I've enjoyed getting to know I like to
mullerian as well I like Bernie a lot to
like him a lot more than I thought I
would like sitting down and talking to
him for three hours on a podcast it's
just like oh you're just you're a person
yeah you're not some crazy old do two
screams out
[Music]
that's when you give three seconds and
she's get yeah that's all you can do one
minute soundbite 30-second sound bite
that's who he is so what's next like
where where where yeah right now I think
our our initial challenge or the the
initial goal that we're seeking to meet
here is to get I've not qualified yet
for the next debate in December what you
have to do to qualify we need to do two
things one is we've got uh surpass
200,000 individual donors that's
hilarious
you need money where are you out right
now we are at I think at about a hundred
ninety nine thousand they'll jump on
that leg of grenade and then the second
thing is is I think require a certain
number of polls and I think I need one
more poll to meet that requirement which
is again is directly like you look at
look at a guy like I think Pete Buddha
judge he spent nine million dollars on
social media ads in order to get like a
four percent bump in the polls you look
at what some of these other guys have
spent some of the billionaires I think
steyr spent 37 million dollars in order
to qualify in the polls on the debate
and so our challenge is we just need to
we need to get out and get in front of
people in order to make sure that that
we're bypassing the corporate media and
we're actually talking directly to folks
at home is there a real possibility that
sometime in our lifetime they can take
money out of politics like that yes
there has to be there has to be the more
people learn about how completely
lopsided our campaign finance system is
that does two things it favors those or
it helps those who are taking money from
corporations and PACs and lobbyists
further deepening the divide between the
politicians and the people that they are
supposed to be serving and representing
and instead you know you've got this
this insider culture of lobbyists and
politicians who are just hanging out and
making the decisions and yeah I mean
look this is the second thing is that
that you're seeing how
how corrupting that influence has is on
the on the politicians and influence
that that they have over people and how
much it's disproportionately helping the
strength and the power of a two-party
system where those parties can can
literally take like for me if if you
wanted to give me a contribution you
could give me the limit is twenty eight
hundred dollars per the primary twenty
Harlow's but that's it you can't no
matter how much you want you can't give
me any more money but if you wanted to
write a check to either the Democratic
Party the Republican Party doesn't
matter unlimited amount of money that
you can give to the party so what does
that actually mean it means the power
the party has a hell of a lot of power
that they can leverage over individual
members of Congress elected leaders to
say if you don't play ball if you don't
vote the way we want you to vote we're
not going to be there to help you out in
your election we're not going to run TV
ads for you we're not going to help you
out when you're getting attacked by the
other guy which just makes the problem
that we already have worse where instead
of leaders voting based on what they
believe is right for their constituents
or right for their the the country or
based on their conscience instead
they're being goaded into voting for the
interests of the political party putting
party ahead of the interests of the
country and so that that's I think the
more people are learning about the
consequence of our existing campaign
finance system the more they're
demanding change and reform so that we
are electing leaders who are accountable
only to the people have you ever had a
conversation with someone where they
have tried to influence your vote in one
way or another in that way that you just
described I have so so you know I have
met with and you know lobbyists will say
hey here's why I want you to vote this
way and you know you know by the way
well we'll be there at your next
fundraising dinner something like that
I have vampires
that's the deal right there and years
ago when I stopped taking PAC money I
got no calls from any lobbyists none
when I said no PAC money no lobbyists
money automatically they're like well
obviously we can't talk to her for not
giving her much crazy lady's not playing
yes exactly and then I I haven't seen it
you know I I established very quickly in
Congress that that I don't play
political games and that I'm not going
to be bullied into taking anybody else's
position if I don't think it's the right
one to take so I have not experienced
that kind of like the the the the party
has never helped me in any of my
elections ever for City Council for
state legislature for Congress so them
coming in and saying well we're not
gonna be like dude you were never there
for me ever anyway but I've seen it
happen with some of my friends who maybe
represent swing districts or who are
Democrats you got elected in a
Republican district they're always gonna
have a really tough race I have seen it
happen in real time where that those
bully tactics come into play
speaking of tactics speaking attacked a
ship strategy and tactics from right now
you're gonna need this when your Madam
President do I have to call you madam
president how's that work is that the
word Madam President that's what say you
something mrs. president because mr.
president and Madam President
yeah that's a weird thing right yeah
maybe this president would be your last
name as president yeah just witnesses
missus generally means you're married
yeah right so yeah I'd Madam President
is what I've seen yeah it has to be it's
just never been done you you should call
always call me Tulsi all right what
madam told ya right now
origen main the website if you want to
get more gin mein kampf orogeny I mean
the state calm if you want to get some
badass keys and jeans straight out of
Jocko thank you softie 2020 calm we need
your help we do tulsi 2020 calm go there
donate let's move the needle thank you
this is very much thank you having us
here my pleasure jacket I thank you
hello
[Music]
mayhem
[Applause]
[Music]